part one approaching the unconscious by
Carl G Jung the importance of dreams man
uses the spoken or written word to
express the meaning of what he wants to
convey his language is full of symbols
but he also often employs signs or
images that are not strictly descriptive
some are mere abbreviations or strings
of initials such as UN UNICEF or UNESCO
others are familiar trademarks the names
of patent medicines badges or insignia
although these are meaningless in
themselves they have acquired a
recognizable meaning through common
usage or deliberate intent such things
are not symbols they are signed and they
do no more than denote the object to
which they are attached what we call a
symbol is a term a name or even a
picture that may be familiar in daily
life yet that possesses specific
connotations in addition to its
conventional and obvious meaning it
implies something vague unknown or
hidden from us many Cretan monuments for
instance are marked with the design of
the double adds this is an object that
we know but we do not know it's symbolic
implications for another example take
the case of the Indian who after a visit
to England told his friends at home that
the English worship animals because he
had found eagles lions and oxen in old
churches he was not aware nor are many
Christians that these animals are
symbols of the evangelists and are
derived from the vision of Ezekiel and
that this in turn has an analogy to the
Egyptian Sun God Horus and his four sons
there are moreover such objects as the
wheel and the cross that are known all
over the world yet that have a symbolic
significance under certain conditions
precisely what they symbolize is still a
matter for controversial speculation
thus a word or an image is symbolic when
it implies something more than its
obvious
and immediate meaning it has a wider
unconscious aspect that is never
precisely defined or fully explained nor
can one hope to define or explain it as
the mind explores the symbol it has led
to ideas that lie beyond the grasp of
reason the wheel may lead our thoughts
toward the concept of a divine Sun but
at this point reason must admit it's
incompetent man is unable to define a
divine being when with all our
intellectual limitations we call
something divine
we have merely given it a name which may
be based on a Creed but never on factual
evidence because there are innumerable
things beyond the range of human
understanding we constantly use symbolic
terms to represent concepts that we
cannot define or fully comprehend this
is one reason why all religions employ
symbolic language or images but this
conscious use of symbols is only one
aspect of a psychological fact of great
importance man also produces symbols
unconsciously and spontaneously in the
form of dreams it is not easy to grasp
to this point but the point must be
grasped if we are to know more about the
ways in which the human mind works then
as we realize if we reflect for a moment
never perceives anything fully or
comprehends anything completely you can
see here touch and taste but how far he
seems how well he hears what his touch
tells him and what he tastes depend upon
the number and quality of his senses
these limit his perception of the world
around him by using scientific
instruments he can partly compensate for
the deficiencies of his senses for
example he can extend the range of his
vision by binoculars or of his hearing
by electrical amplification but the most
elaborate apparatus cannot do more than
bring distant or small objects within
range of his eyes or make faint sounds
more audible no matter what instrument
he uses at some point he reaches the
edge of certainty beyond which conscious
knowledge cannot pass there are moreover
unconscious aspects of our perception of
reality the first is the fact that even
when our senses react to real phenomena
sights and sounds they are somehow
translated from the realm of reality
into that of the mind within the mind
they become psychic events whose
ultimate nature is unknowable for the
psyche cannot know its own psychical
substance thus every experience contains
an indefinite number of unknown factors
not to speak of the fact that every
concrete object is always unknown in
certain respects because we cannot know
the ultimate nature of matter itself
then there are certain events of which
we have not consciously taken note they
have remained so to speak below the
threshold of consciousness they have
happened but they have been absorbed
subliminally without our conscious
knowledge we can become aware of such
happenings only in a moment of intuition
or by a process of profound thought that
leads to a later realization that they
must have happened and though we may
have originally ignored their emotional
and vital importance it later Wells up
from the unconscious as a sort of
afterthought it may appear for instance
in the form of a dream as a general rule
the unconscious aspect of any event is
revealed to us in dreams where it
appears not as a rational thought but as
a symbolic image as a matter of history
it was the study of dreams that first
enabled psychologists to investigate the
unconscious aspect of conscious psychic
events it is on such evidence that
psychologists assume the existence of an
unconscious psyche though many
scientists and philosophers deny its
existence they argue naively that such
an assumption implies the existence of
two subjects or to put it in a common
phrase two personalities within the same
individual but this is exactly what it
does imply quite correctly and it is one
of the curses of modern man that many
people suffer from this divided
personality it is by no means of
pathological symptom it is a normal fact
that can be observed at any time and
everywhere it is not merely the neurotic
whose right hand does not know what the
left hand is due
this predicament is a symptom of a
general unconsciousness that is the
undeniable common inheritance of all
mankind man has developed consciousness
slowly in laborious life in a process
that took untold ages to reach the
civilized state which is arbitrarily
dated from the invention of script in
about 4000 BC and this evolution is far
from complete for large areas of the
human mind are still shrouded in
darkness what we call the psyche is by
no means identical with our
consciousness and its contents whoever
denies the existence of the unconscious
is in fact assuming that our present
knowledge of the psyche is total and
this belief is clearly just as false as
the assumption that we know all there is
to be known about the natural universe
our psyche is part of nature and it's
enigma is as limitless thus we cannot
define either the psyche or nature we
can merely state what we believe them to
be and describe as best we can how they
function quite apart therefore from the
evidence that medical research is
accumulated there are strong grounds of
logic for rejecting statements like
there is no unconscious those who say
such things
merely express an age-old Missoni ism a
fear of the new and the unknown there
are historical reasons for this
resistance to the idea of an unknown
part of the human psyche consciousness
is a very recent acquisition of nature
and it is still in an experimental state
it is frail menaced by specific dangers
and easily injured as anthropologists
have noted one of the most common mental
derangement that occur among primitive
people is what they call the loss of a
soul which means as the name indicates a
noticeable disruption or more
technically a dissociation of
consciousness among such people whose
consciousness is at a different level of
development from ours the soul or psyche
is not felt to be a unit many primitives
assume that a man has a bush soul as
well as his own and that this bush soul
is incarnate in a wild animal or a tree
with which
the human individual has some kind of
psychic identity this is what the
distinguished french ethnologist this
young lady pollutants called a mystical
participation he later retracted this
term under pressure of adverse criticism
but I believe that his critics were
wrong it is a well-known psychological
fact that an individual may have such an
unconscious identity with some other
person or object this identity takes a
variety of forms among primitives if the
bush soul is that of an animal the
animal itself is considered as some sort
of brother to the man a man whose
brother is a crocodile for instance is
supposed to be safe when swimming a
crocodile-infested River if the bush
soul is a tree the tree is presumed to
have something like parental authority
over the individual concerned in both
cases an injury to the bush soul is
interpreted as an injury to the man in
some tribes it is assumed that a man has
a number of souls
this belief expresses the feeling of
some primitive individuals that they
each consists of several linked but
distinct units this means that the
individual psyche is far from being
safely synthesized on the contrary it
threatens to fragment only too easily
under the onslaught of unchecked
emotions while this situation is
familiar to us from the studies of
anthropologists it is not so irrelevant
to our own advanced civilization as it
might seem we too can become dissociated
and lose our identity we can be
possessed and altered by moods or become
unreasonable and unable to recall
important facts about ourselves or
others so that people ask what the devil
has got into you we talk about being
able to control ourselves but
self-control is a rare and remarkable
virtue we may think we have ourselves
under control yet a friend can easily
tell us things about ourselves of which
we have no knowledge beyond doubt even
in what we call a high level of
civilization human consciousness has not
yet achieved a reasonable degree of
continuity it is still vulnerable and
liable to fragmentation this capacity to
isolate part of one's
and indeed is a valuable characteristic
it enables us to concentrate upon one
thing at a time excluding everything
else that may claim our attention but
there is a world of difference between a
conscious decision to split off and
temporarily suppress a part of one's
psyche and a condition in which this
happens spontaneously without one's
knowledge or consent and even against
one's intention the former is a
civilized achievement the latter of
primitive loss of a soul or even the
pathological cause of a neurosis thus
even in our day the unity of
consciousness is still a doubtful affair
it can too easily be disrupted an
ability to control one's emotions that
may be very desirable from one point of
view would be a questionable
accomplishment from another for it would
deprive social intercourse of variety
color and warmth it is against this
background that we must review the
importance of dreams those flimsy
evasive unreliable vague and uncertain
fantasies to explain my point of view I
should like to describe how it developed
over a period of years and how I was led
to conclude that dreams are the most
frequent and universally accessible
source for the investigation of men
symbolizing faculty Sigmund Freud was
the pioneer who first tried to explore
empirically the unconscious background
of consciousness he worked on the
general assumption that dreams are not a
matter of chance but are associated with
conscious thoughts and problems this
assumption was not in the least
arbitrary it was based upon the
conclusion of eminent neurologists for
instance pierre-jean a that neurotic
symptoms are related to some conscious
experience they even appear to be split
off areas of the conscious mind which at
another time and under different
conditions can be conscious before the
beginning of this century for arredondo
Sequoyah had recognized that neurotic
symptoms hysteria certain types of pain
and abnormal behavior are in fact
symbolically meaningful they are one way
in which the unconscious mind expresses
itself
just as it may in dreams and they are
equally symbolic a patient for instance
who is confronted with an intolerable
situation may develop a spasm whenever
he tries to swallow he can't swallow it
under similar conditions of
psychological stress another patient has
an attack of asthma he can't breathe the
atmosphere at home
a third suffers from a peculiar
paralysis of the legs he can't walk that
is he can't go on anymore a fourth who
vomits when he eats cannot digest some
unpleasant fact I could cite many
examples of this kind but such physical
reactions are only one form in which the
problems that trouble us unconsciously
may express themselves they more often
find expression in our dreams any
psychologist who has listened to numbers
of people describing their dreams knows
that dream symbols have much greater
variety than the physical symptoms of
neurosis they often consist of elaborate
and picturesque fantasies but if the
analyst who is confronted by this dream
material uses Freud's original technique
of free association he finds that dreams
can eventually be reduced to certain
basic patterns this technique played an
important part in the development of
psychoanalysis
for it enabled Freud to use dreams as
the starting point from which the
unconscious problem of the patient might
be explored Freud made the simple but
penetrating observation that if a
dreamer is encouraged to go on talking
about his dream images and the thoughts
that these prompt in his mind he will
give himself away and reveal the
unconscious background of his ailment in
both what he says and what he
deliberately omit saying his ideas may
seem irrational and irrelevant but after
a time it becomes relatively easy to see
what it is that he is trying to avoid
what unpleasant thought or experience he
is suppressing no matter how he tries to
camouflage it everything he says points
to the core of his predicament a doctor
sees so many things from the seamy side
of life that he has seldom far from the
truth when he interprets the hints the
patient produces as signs of an uneasy
conscience what he eventually discovers
unfortunately confirms his expectations
thus far nobody can say anything against
Freud's theory of repression and wish
fulfillment as apparent causes of dream
symbolism Freud attached particular
importance to dreams as the point of
departure for a process of free
association but after a time I began to
feel that this was a misleading and
inadequate use of the rich fantasies
that the unconscious produces in sleep
my doubts really began when a colleague
told me of an experience he had during
the course of a long train journey in
Russia though he did not know the
language and could not even decipher the
Cyrillic script he found himself musing
over the strange letters in which the
railway notices were written and he fell
into a reverie in which he imagined all
sorts of meanings for them one idea led
to another and in his relaxed mood he
found that this free association had
stirred up many old memories among them
he was annoyed to find some long buried
disagreeable topics things he had wished
to forget and had forgotten consciously
he had in fact arrived at what
psychologists would call his complexes
that is repressed emotional themes that
can cause constant psychological
disturbances or even in many cases the
symptoms of neurosis this episode opened
my eyes to the fact that it was not
necessary to use a dream as the point of
departure for the process of free
association if one wished to discover
the complexes of a patient it showed me
that one can reach the center directly
from any point of the compass one could
begin from Cyrillic letters from
meditations upon a crystal ball a prayer
wheel or a modern painting or even from
casual conversation about some quite
trivial event the dream was no more and
no less useful in this respect than any
other possible starting point
nevertheless dreams have a particular
significance even though they often
arise from an emotional upset in which
the habitual complexes are also involved
the habitual complexes are the tender
spots of the psyche which react most
quickly to an external stimulus or
disturbance that is why free association
can lead one from any dream to the
critical secret thoughts at this point
however it occurred to me that if I was
right so far it might reasonably follow
that dreams have some special and more
significant function of their own very
often dreams have a definite evidently
purposeful structure indicating an
underlying idea or intention though as a
rule the latter is not immediately
comprehensible I therefore began to
consider whether one should pay more
attention to the actual form and content
of a dream rather than allowing free
association to lead one off through a
train of ideas to complexes that could
as easily be reached by other means this
new thought was a turning point in the
development of my psychology it meant
that I gradually gave up following
associations that led far away from the
text of a dream I chose to concentrate
rather on the associations to the dream
itself believing that the latter
expressed something specific that the
unconscious was trying to say the change
in my attitude toward dreams involved a
change of method the new technique was
one that could take account of all the
various wider aspects of a dream a story
told by the conscious mind has a
beginning of development and an end but
the same is not true of a dream its
dimensions in time and space are quite
different to understand that you must
examine it from every aspect just as you
may take an unknown object in your hands
and turn it over and over until you are
familiar with every detail of its shape
perhaps I have now said enough to show
how I came increasingly to disagree with
free association as Freud first employed
it I wanted to keep as close as possible
to the dream itself and to exclude all
the irrelevant ideas and associations
that it might evoke
true these could lead one toward the
complexes of a patient but I had a more
far-reaching purpose in mind than the
discovery of complexes that cause not
disturbances there are many other means
by which these can be identified the
psychologist for instance can get all
the hints he needs by using word
association tests by asking the patient
what he Associates to a given set of
words and by studying his responses but
to know and understand the psychic life
process of an individual's whole
personality it is important to realize
that his dreams and their symbolic
images have a much more important role
to play almost everyone knows for
example that there is an enormous
variety of images by which the sexual
act can be symbolized or one might say
represented in the form of an allegory
each of these images can lead by a
process of Association to the idea of
sexual intercourse and to specific
complexes that any individual may have
about his own sexual attitudes but one
could just as well on earth such
complexes by daydreaming on a set of
indecipherable Russian letters I was
thus led to the assumption that a dream
can contain some message other than the
sexual allegory and that it does so for
definite reasons to illustrate this
point a man may dream of inserting a key
in a lock of wielding a heavy stick or
breaking down a door with a battering
ram each of these can be regarded as a
sexual allegory but the fact that his
unconscious for its own purposes has
chosen one of these specific images it
may be the key the stick or the
battering ram is also of major
significance the real task is to
understand why the key has been
preferred to the stick or the stick to
the RAM and sometimes this might even
lead one to discover that it is not the
sexual act at all that is represented
but some quite different psychological
point from this line of reasoning I
concluded that only the material that is
clearly and visibly part of a dream
should be used in interpreting it the
dream has its own limitation its
specific form itself tells us what
belongs to it and what leads away from
it while free association lures one away
from that mature
in a kind of zigzag line the method I
evolved is more like a circumambulation
whose center is the dream picture I work
all around the dream picture and
disregard every attempt that the dreamer
makes to break away from it time and
time again in my professional work I
have had to repeat the words let's get
back to your dream what does the dream
say for instance a patient of mine
dreamed of a drunken and disheveled
vulgar woman in the dream it seemed that
this woman was his wife though in real
life his wife was totally different on
the surface therefore the dream was
shockingly untrue and the patient
immediately rejected it as dream
nonsense if I as his doctor had let him
start a process of Association he would
inevitably have tried to get as far away
as possible from the unpleasant
suggestion of his dream in that case he
would have ended with one of his staple
complexes a complex possibly that had
nothing to do with his wife and we
should have learned nothing about the
special meaning of this particular dream
what then was his unconscious trying to
convey by such an obviously untrue
statement clearly it somehow expressed
the idea of a degenerate female who was
closely connected with the dreamers life
but since the projection of this image
onto his wife was unjustified and
factually untrue I had to look elsewhere
before I found out what this repulsive
image represented in the middle ages
long before the physiologists
demonstrated that by reason of our
glandular structure there are both male
and female elements in all of us it was
said that every man carries a woman
within himself it is this female element
in every male that I have called the
anima this feminine aspect is
essentially a certain inferior kind of
relatedness to the surroundings and
particularly to women which is kept
carefully concealed from others as well
as from oneself in other words though an
individual's visible personality may
seem quite normal he may well be
concealing from others or even from
himself
the deplorable condition
the woman within that was the case with
this particular patient his female side
was not nice his dream was actually
saying to him you are in some respects
behaving like a degenerate female and
thus gave him an appropriate shock an
example of this kind of course must not
be taken as evidence that the
unconscious is concerned with moral
injunctions the dream was not telling
the patient to behave better but was
simply trying to balance the lopsided
nature of his conscious mind which was
maintaining the fiction that he was a
perfect gentleman throughout it is easy
to understand why dreamers tend to
ignore and even deny the message of
their dreams
consciousness naturally resists anything
unconscious and unknown I have already
pointed out the existence among
primitive peoples of what
anthropologists call Missoni ISM a
deepened superstitious fear of novelty
the primitives manifest all the
reactions of the wild animal against
untoward events but civilized man reacts
to new ideas in much the same way
erecting psychological barriers to
protect himself from the shock of facing
something new this can easily be
observed in any individual's reaction to
his own dreams when obliged to admit a
surprising thought many pioneers in
philosophy science and even literature
have been victims of the innate
conservatism of their contemporaries
psychology is one of the youngest of the
sciences because of attempts to deal
with the working of the unconscious it
is inevitably encountered missiny ism in
an extreme form past and future in the
unconscious so far I have been sketching
some of the principles on which I
approached the problem of Dreams for
when we want to investigate man's
faculty to produce symbols Green has
proved to be the most basic and
accessible material for this purpose the
two fundamental points in dealing with
dreams are these first the dream should
be treated as a fact about which one
must make no previous assumption except
that it somehow makes sense and second
the dream is a specific
expression of the unconscious one could
scarcely put these principles more
modestly no matter how low anyone's
opinion of the unconscious may be he
must concede that it is worth
investigating the unconscious is at
least on a level with the Laos which
after all enjoys the Honest interest of
the entomologist if somebody with little
experience and knowledge of dreams
thinks that dreams are just chaotic
occurrences without meaning he is at
liberty to do so but if one assumes that
they are normal events which is a matter
of fact they are one is bound to
consider that they are either causal
that is that there is a rational cause
for their existence or in a certain way
purposive or both let us now look a
little more closely at the ways in which
the conscious and unconscious contents
of the mind are linked together take an
example with which everyone is familiar
suddenly you find you cannot remember
what you were going to say next though a
moment ago the thought was perfectly
clear or perhaps you were about to
introduce a friend and his name escaped
you as you were about to utter it you
say you cannot remember in fact though
the thought has become unconscious or at
least momentarily separated from
consciousness we find the same
phenomenon with our senses if we listen
to a continuous note on the fringe of
audibility the sound seems to stop at
regular intervals and then start again
such oscillations are due to a periodic
decrease and increase in one's attention
not to any change in the note but when
something slips out of our consciousness
it does not cease to exist
any more than a car that has disappeared
round a corner has vanished into thin
air it is simply out of sight just as we
may later see the car again so we come
across thoughts that were temporarily
lost to us thus part of the unconscious
consists of a multitude of temporarily
obscured thoughts impressions and images
that in spite of being lost continue to
influence our conscious minds a man who
is distracted or absent-minded will walk
across the room to fetch something
he stops scene
perplexed he is forgotten what he was
after his hands grope about among the
objects on the table as if he were
sleepwalking he is oblivious of his
original purpose yet he is unconsciously
guided by it then he realizes what it is
that he wants his unconscious has
prompted him if you observe the behavior
of a neurotic person you can see him
doing many things that he appears to be
doing consciously and purposefully yet
if you ask him about them you will
discover that he is either unconscious
of them or has something quite different
in mind
he hears and does not hear he sees yet
his blind he knows and is ignorant such
examples are so common that the
specialist soon realizes that
unconscious contents of the mind behave
as if they were conscious and that you
can never be sure in such cases where
the thoughts speech or action is
conscious or not it is this kind of
behavior that makes so many physicians
dismiss statements by hysterical
patients as utter lies such persons
certainly produce more on truths than
most of us but lie is scarcely the right
word to use in fact their mental state
causes an uncertainty of behavior
because their consciousness is liable to
unpredictable Eclipse by an interference
from the unconscious even their skin
sensations may reveal similar
fluctuations of awareness at one moment
the hysterical person may feel a needle
prick in the arm at the next it may pass
unnoticed if his attention can be
focused on a certain point the whole of
his body can be completely anesthetized
until the tension that causes this
blackout of the senses has been relaxed
sense perception is then immediately
restored all the time however he has
been unconsciously aware of what was
happening the physician can see this
process quite clearly when he hypnotizes
such a patient it is easy to demonstrate
that the patient has been aware of every
detail the prick in the arm where the
remark made during an eclipse of
consciousness can be recalled as
accurately as if there had been no
anesthesia or for
fulness I recall a woman who was once
admitted to the clinic in a state of
complete stupor when she recovered
consciousness next day she knew who she
was but did not know where she was how
or why she had come there or even the
date yet after I had hypnotized her she
told me why she had fallen ill how she
had got to the clinic and who had
admitted her all these details could be
verified she was even able to tell the
time at which she had been admitted
because she had seen a clock in the
entrance hall under hypnosis her memory
was as clear as if she had been
completely conscious all the time when
we discussed such matters we usually
have to draw on evidence supplied by
clinical observation for this reason
many critics assume that the unconscious
and all its subtle manifestations belong
solely to the sphere of psychopathology
they consider any expression of the
unconscious as something neurotic or
psychotic which has nothing to do with a
normal mental state but neurotic
phenomena are by no means the products
exclusively of disease they are in fact
no more than pathological exaggerations
of normal occurrences it is only because
they are exaggerations that they are
more obvious than their normal
counterparts hysterical symptoms can be
observed in all normal persons but they
are so slight that they usually pass
unnoticed forgetting for instance is a
normal process in which certain
conscious ideas lose their specific
energy because one's attention has been
deflected when interest turns elsewhere
it leaves in shadow the things with
which one was previously concerned just
as a searchlight lights up a new area by
leaving another in darkness
this is unavoidable for consciousness
can keep only a few images in full
clarity at one time and even this
clarity fluctuates but the Forgotten
ideas have not ceased to exist although
they cannot be reproduced at will they
are present in a subliminal state just
beyond the threshold of recall from
which they can rise again spontaneously
at any time often after many years of
apparently total oblivion I am speaking
here of things we have consciously seen
or her
and subsequently forgotten but we all
see hear smell and taste many things
without noticing them at the time either
because our attention is deflected or
because the stimulus to our senses is
too slight to leave a conscious
impression the unconscious however has
taken note of them and such subliminal
sense perceptions play a significant
part in our everyday lives without our
realizing it they influence the way in
which we react to both events and people
an example of this that I found
particularly revealing was provided by a
professor who had been walking in the
country with one of his pupils absorbed
in serious conversation suddenly he
noticed that his thoughts were being
interrupted by an unexpected flow of
memories from his early childhood he
could not account for this distraction
nothing in what had been said seemed to
have any connection with these memories
on looking back he saw that he had been
walking past a farm when the first of
these childhood recollections had surged
up in his mind he suggested to his pupil
that they should walk back to the point
where the fantasies had begun once there
he noticed the smell of geese and
instantly he realized that it was this
smell that had touched off the flow of
memories in his youth he had lived on a
farm where geese were kept and their
characteristic smell had left a lasting
though forgotten impression as he passed
the farm on his walk he had noticed the
smell subliminally and this unconscious
perception had called back
long-forgotten experiences of his
childhood the perception was subliminal
because the attention was engaged
elsewhere and the stimulus was not
strong enough to deflect it and to reach
consciousness directly yet it had
brought up the forgotten memories such a
cue or trigger effect can explain the
onset of neurotic symptoms as well as
more benign memories when a sight smell
or sound recalls a circumstance in the
past a girl for instance may be busy in
her office
apparently in good health and spirits a
moment later she develops a blinding
headache and shows other signs of
distress without consciously noticing it
she has heard the
Horn of a distant ship and this is
unconsciously reminded her of an unhappy
parting with a lover whom she has been
doing her best to forget
aside from normal forgetting Freud has
described several cases that involve the
forgetting of disagreeable memories
memories that one is only too ready to
lose as Nietzsche remarked where pride
is insistent enough memory prefers to
give way thus among the lost memories we
encounter not a few that oh they're
subliminal state and their incapacity to
be voluntarily reproduced to their
disagreeable and incompatible nature the
psychologist calls these repressed
contents a case in point might be that
of a secretary who is jealous of one of
her employers associates
she habitually forgets to invite this
person to meetings though the name is
clearly marked on the list she is using
but if challenged on the point she
simply said as she forgot or was
interrupted she never admits not even to
herself the real reason for her omission
many people mistakenly overestimate the
role of willpower and think that nothing
can happen to their minds that they do
not decide and intend but one must learn
to discriminate carefully between
intentional and unintentional contents
of the mind the former are derived from
the ego personality the latter however
arise from a source that is not
identical with the ego but is its other
side it is this other side that would
have made the secretary forget the
invitations there are many reasons why
we forget things that we have noticed or
experience and there are just as many
ways in which they may be recalled to
mind an interesting example is that of
Krypton Eva or concealed recollection an
author may be writing steadily to a
preconceived plan working out an
argument or developing the line of the
story when he suddenly runs off at a
tangent perhaps a fresh idea has
occurred to him or a different image or
a whole new subplot if you ask him what
prompted the digression he will not be
able to tell you he may not even have
noticed the change though he has now
produced material that is entirely fresh
and apparently unknown to him before yet
it can sometimes be shown convincingly
that what he is written there's a
striking similarity to the work of
another author a work that he believes
he has never seen I myself found a
fascinating example of this in
Nietzsche's book thus spake Zarathustra
where the author reproduces almost
word-for-word an incident reported in a
ship's log for the year 1686
by sheer chance I had read this seaman's
yarn in a book published about 1835 half
a century before Nietzsche wrote and
when I found the similar passage in thus
spake Zarathustra I was struck by its
peculiar style which was different from
Nietzsche's usual language I was
convinced that Nietzsche must also have
seen the old book though he made no
reference to it
I wrote to his sister who was still
alive and she confirmed that she and her
brother had in fact read the book
together when he was 11 years old I
think from the context it is
inconceivable that Nietzsche had any
idea that he was plagiarizing this story
I believe that 50 years later it had
unexpectedly slipped into focus in his
conscious mind note Nietzsche scriptum
neva is discussed in Jung's on the
psychology of so-called occult phenomena
in collected works Volume one the
relevant passage from the ship's log and
the corresponding passage from Nietzsche
are as follows from jkerner letter
Osprey Vorst volume 4 page 57 headed an
extract of our inspiring import
originally 1831 237 the four captains
and the merchant mr. Bell went ashore on
the island of Mount Stromlo Lee to shoot
rabbits at three o'clock they mustered
the crew to go aboard when to their
inexpressible astonishment they saw two
men flying rapidly toward them through
the air one was dressed in black the
other in gray they came past them very
closely
in greatest haste and to their utmost
dismay descended into
crater of the terrible volcano Mount
Stromboli they recognized the pair as
acquaintances from London from F
Nietzsche thus spake Zarathustra chapter
40 great events translated by common
page 180 slightly modified originally
1883 now about the time that Zarathustra
sojourned on the Happy Isles it happened
that a ship anchored at the Isle on
which the smoking Mountain stand and the
crew went ashore to shoot rabbits about
the noontide hour however when the
captain and his men were together again
they suddenly saw a man coming toward
them through the air and the voice said
distinctly it is time it is highest time
but when the figure drew close to them
flying past quickly like a shadow in the
direction of the volcano
they recognized with the greatest dismay
that it was Zarathustra behold said the
old helmsman Zarathustra goes down to
hell end of note in this type of case
there is genuine if unrealized
recollection much the same sort of thing
may happen to a musician who has heard a
peasant tune or popular song in
childhood and finds it cropping up as
the theme of a symphonic movement that
he is composing in adult life an idea or
an image has moved back from the
unconscious into the conscious mind what
I have so far said about the unconscious
is no more than a cursory sketch of the
nature and functioning of this complex
part of the human psyche but it should
have indicated the kind of subliminal
material from which the symbols of our
dreams may be spontaneously produced
this subliminal material can consist of
all urges impulses and intentions all
perceptions and intuitions all rational
or irrational thoughts conclusions
inductions deductions and premises and
all varieties of feeling any or all of
these can take the form of partial
temporary or constant unconsciousness
such material has mostly become
unconscious because in a manner of
there is no room for it in the conscious
mind some of one's thoughts lose their
emotional energy and become subliminal
that is to say they no longer received
so much of our conscious attention
because they have come to seem
uninteresting or irrelevant or because
there is some reason why we wish to push
them out of sight it is in fact normal
and necessary for us to forget in this
fashion in order to make room in our
conscious minds for new impressions and
ideas if this did not happen everything
we experienced would remain above the
threshold of consciousness and our minds
would become impossibly cluttered this
phenomenon is so widely recognized today
that most people who know anything about
psychology take it for granted but just
as conscious contents can vanish into
the unconscious new contents which have
never yet been conscious can arise from
it one may have an inkling for instance
that something is on the point of
breaking into consciousness that
something is in the air or that one
smells a rat the discovery that the
unconscious is no mere depository of the
past but is also full of germs of future
psychic situations and ideas led me to
my own new approach to psychology a
great deal of controversial discussion
has arisen around this point but it is a
fact that in addition to memories from a
long distant conscious past completely
new thoughts and creative ideas can also
present themselves from the unconscious
thoughts and ideas that have never been
conscious before they grow up from the
dark depths of the mind like a lotus and
form a most important part of the
subliminal psyche we find this in
everyday life where dilemmas are
sometimes solved by the most surprising
new propositions many artists
philosophers and even scientists or some
of their best ideas - inspirations that
appear suddenly from the unconscious the
ability to reach a rich vein of such
material and to translate it effectively
into philosophy literature music or
scientific discovery is one of the
hallmarks of what is commonly called
genius we can find clear proof of this
fact in the history of science itself
for example the French mathematician
pong cafe and
chemist Kaku lay all the important
scientific discoveries as they
themselves admit to sudden pictorial
revelations from the unconscious the
so-called mystical experience of the
French philosopher Descartes involved a
similar sudden revelation in which he
saw in a flash the order of all Sciences
the British author Robert Louis
Stevenson had spent years looking for a
story that would fit his strong sense of
man's double being when the plot of dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde was suddenly
revealed to him in a dream later I shall
describe in more detail how such
material arises from the unconscious and
I shall examine the form in which it is
expressed at the moment I simply want to
point out that the capacity of the human
psyche to produce such new material is
particularly significant when one is
dealing with dream symbolism for I have
found again and again in my professional
work that the images and ideas that
dreams contain cannot possibly be
explained solely in terms of memory they
express new thoughts that have never yet
reached the threshold of consciousness
the function of Dreams I have gone into
some detail about the origins of our
dream life because it is the soil from
which most symbols originally grow
unfortunately dreams are difficult to
understand as I have already pointed out
the dream is quite unlike the story told
by the conscious mind in everyday life
one thinks out what one wants to say
selects the most telling way of saying
it and tries to make one's remarks
logically coherent for instance an
educated person will seek to avoid a
mixed metaphor because it may give a
muddled impression of his point but
dreams have a different texture images
that seem contradictory and ridiculous
crowd in on the dreamer the normal sense
of time is lost and commonplace things
can assume a fascinating or threatening
aspect it may seem strange that the
unconscious mind should order its
material so differently from the
seemingly disciplined pattern that we
can impose on our thoughts in waking
life yet anyone who stops for a moment
to recall a dream will be aware of this
contrast
which is in fact one of the main reasons
why the ordinary person finds dreams so
hard to understand they do not make
sense in terms of his normal waking
experience and therefore he is inclined
either to disregard them or to confess
that they baffle him perhaps it may be
easier to understand this point if we
first realized the fact that the ideas
with which we deal in our apparently
disciplined waking life are by no means
as precise as we like to believe on the
contrary their meaning and their
emotional significance for us becomes
more imprecise the more closely we
examine them the reason for this is that
anything we have heard or experienced
can become subliminal that is to say can
pass into the unconscious and even what
we retain in our conscious mind and can
reproduce at will has acquired an
unconscious undertone that will color
the idea each time it is recalled our
conscious impressions in fact quickly
assume an element of unconscious meaning
that is psychically significant for us
though we are not consciously aware of
the existence of this subliminal meaning
or of the way in which it both extends
and confuses the conventional meaning of
course such psychic undertones differ
from one person to another each of us
receives any abstract or general notion
in the context of the individual mind
and we therefore understand and apply it
in our individual ways when in
conversation I use any such terms as
state money health or society I assume
that my listeners understand more or
less the same thing as I do but the
phrase more or less makes my point each
word means something slightly different
to each person even among those who
share the same cultural background the
reason for this variation is that a
general notion is received into an
individual context and is therefore
understood and applied in a slightly
individual way and the difference of
meaning is naturally greatest when
people have widely different social
political religious or psychological
experiences as long as concepts are
identical with mere words the variation
is almost imperceptible and plays no
practical role but when an exact
definition
or a careful explanation is needed one
can occasionally discover the most
amazing variations not only in the
purely intellectual understanding of the
term but particularly in its emotional
tone and its application as a rule these
variations are subliminal and therefore
it never realized one may tend to
dismiss such differences as redundant or
expendable nuances of meaning that have
little relevance to everyday needs but
the fact that they exist shows that even
the most matter-of-fact contents of
consciousness have a penumbra of
uncertainty around them even the most
carefully defined philosophical or
mathematical concept which we are sure
does not contain more than we have put
into it is nevertheless more than we
assume it is a psychic event and as such
partly unknowable the very numbers you
use in counting are more than you take
them to be they are at the same time
mythological elements
for the pythagoreans they were even
divine but you are certainly unaware of
this when you use numbers for a
practical purpose every concept in our
conscious mind in short as its own
psychic associations while such
associations may vary in intensity
according to the relative importance of
the concept to our whole personality or
according to the other ideas and even
complexes to which it is associated in
our unconscious they are capable of
changing the normal character of that
concept it may even become something
quite different as a drift below the
level of consciousness these subliminal
aspects of everything that happens to us
may seem to play very little part in our
daily lives but in dream analysis where
the psychologist is dealing with
expressions of the unconscious they are
very relevant for they are the almost
invisible roots of our conscious
thoughts that is why commonplace objects
or ideas can assume such powerful
psychic significance in a dream that we
may awake seriously disturbed in spite
of having dreamed of nothing worse than
a locked room or a missed train the
images produced in dreams are much more
picturesque and vivid than the concepts
and experiences that are their waking
counterparts one of the reasons for this
is that in a dream such concepts can
express their unconscious meaning in our
conscious thoughts we restrain ourselves
within the limits of rational statements
statements that are much less colorful
because we have stripped them of most of
their psychic associations I recall one
dream of my own that I found difficult
to interpret in this dream a certain man
was trying to get behind me and jump on
my back I knew nothing of this man
except that I was aware that he had
somehow picked up a remark I had made
and had twisted it into a grotesque
travesty of my meaning but I could not
see the connection between this fact and
his attempt in the dream to jump on me
in my professional life however it has
often happened that someone has
misrepresented what I have said so often
that I have scarcely bothered to wonder
whether this kind of misrepresentation
makes me angry now there is a certain
value in keeping a conscious control
over one's emotional reaction
and this I soon realized was the point
the dream had made it had taken an
Austrian colloquialism and translated it
into a pictorial image this phrase
common enough in ordinary speech is du
Const meer often Buccleuch Tigan you can
climb on my back which means I don't
care what you say about me an American
equivalent which could easily appear in
a similar dream would be go jump in the
lake one could say that this dream
picture was symbolic for it did not
state the situation directly but Express
the point indirectly by means of a
metaphor that I could not at first
understand when this happens as it so
often does it is not deliberate
disguised by a dream it simply reflects
the deficiencies in our understanding of
emotionally-charged pictorial language
for in our daily experience we need the
state things as accurately as possible
and we have learned to discard the
trimmings of fantasy both in our
language and in our thoughts thus losing
a quality that is still characteristic
of the primitive mind most of us have
consigned to the unconscious all the
fantastic psychic associations that
every object or idea possesses the
primitive on the other hand is still
aware of these psychic properties he
endowed animals plants or stones with
powers that we find strange and
unacceptable an African jungle dweller
for instance sees a nocturnal creature
by daylight and knows it to be a
medicine man who has temporarily taken
its shape or ami regarded as the bush
soul or ancestral spirit of one of his
tribe a tree may play a vital part in
the life of a primitive apparently
possessing for him its own soul and
voice and the man concerned will feel
that he shares its fate there are some
Indians in South America who will assure
you that they are red Aurora parrots
though they are well aware that they
lack feathers wings and beaks for in the
primitives world things do not have the
same sharp boundaries they do in our
rational societies what psychologists
call psychic identity or mystical
participation has been stripped off our
world of things but it is exactly this
halo of unconscious association
that gives a colorful and fantastic
aspect to the primitives world we have
lost it to such a degree that we do not
recognize it when we meet it again with
us such things are kept below the
threshold when they occasionally
reappear
we even insist that something is wrong I
have more than once been consulted by
well-educated and intelligent people who
have had peculiar dreams fantasies or
even visions which have shocked them
deeply they have assumed that no one who
was in a sound state of mind could
suffer from such things and that anyone
who actually sees a vision must be
pathologically disturbed a theologian
once told me that Ezekiel's visions were
nothing more than morbid symptoms and
that when Moses and other prophets heard
voices speaking to them they were
suffering from hallucinations you can
imagine the panic he felt when something
of this kind spontaneously happened to
him we are so accustomed to the
apparently rational nature of our world
that we can scarcely imagine anything
happening that cannot be explained by
common sense the primitive man
confronted by a shock of this kind would
not doubt his sanity he would think of
fetishes spirits or gods yet the
emotions that affect us are just the
same in fact the terrors that stem from
our elaborate civilization may be far
more threatening than those that
primitive people attribute to demons the
attitude of modern civilized man
sometimes reminds me of a psychotic
patient in my clinic who was himself a
doctor one morning I asked him how he
was he replied that he had had a
wonderful night disinfecting the whole
of heaven with mercuric chloride but
that in the course of this thorough
going sanitary process he had found no
trace of God here we see a neurosis or
something worse instead of God or the
fear of God there is an anxiety neurosis
or some kind of phobia the emotion has
remained the same but its object has
changed both its name and nature for the
worse I recall a professor of philosophy
who once consulted me about his cancer
phobia
he suffered from a compulsive conviction
that he had a malignant tumor although
nothing of
kind was ever found in dozens of x-ray
pictures oh I know there is nothing he
would say but there might be something
what was it that produced this idea it
obviously came from a fear that was not
instilled by conscious deliberation the
morbid thought suddenly overcame him and
it had a power of its own that he could
not control it was far more difficult
for this educated man to make an
admission of this kind than it would
have been for a primitive to say that he
was plagued by a ghost
the malign influence of evil spirits is
at least an admissible hypothesis in a
primitive culture but it is a shattering
experience for a civilized person to
admit that his troubles are nothing more
than a foolish prank of the imagination
the primitive phenomenon of obsession
has not vanished it is the same as ever
it is only interpreted in a different
and more obnoxious way I have made
several comparisons of this kind between
modern and primitive man such
comparisons as I shall show later are
essential to an understanding of the
symbol making propensity of man and of
the part that dreams play in expressing
them for one finds that many dreams
present images and associations that are
analogous to primitive ideas myths and
rites these dream images were called
archaic remnants by Freud the phrase
suggests that they are psychic elements
surviving in the human mind from ages
long ago this point of view is
characteristic of those who regard the
unconscious as a mere appendix of
consciousness or more picturesque Allah
as a trash can that collects all the
refuse of the conscious mind further
investigation suggested to me that this
attitude is untenable and should be
discarded
I found that associations and images of
this kind are an integral part of the
unconscious and can be observed
everywhere whether the dreamer is
educated or illiterate intelligent or
stupid they are not in any sense
lifeless or meaningless remnants they
still function and they are especially
valuable as dr. Henderson shows in a
later chapter of this book just because
of their historical nature they form a
bridge between
the ways in which we consciously express
our thoughts and a more primitive more
colorful and pictorial form of
expression it is this form as well that
appeals directly to feeling and emotion
these historical associations are the
link between the rational world of
consciousness and the world of instinct
I have already discussed the interesting
contrast between the controlled thoughts
we have in waking life and the wealth of
imagery produced in dreams now you can
see another reason for this difference
because in our civilized life
we have stripped so many ideas of their
emotional energy we do not really
respond to them anymore we use such
ideas in our speech and we show a
conventional reaction when others use
them but they do not make a very deep
impression on us something more is
needed to bring certain things home to
us effectively enough to make us change
our attitude and behavior this is what
dream language does its symbolism has so
much psychic energy that we are forced
to pay attention to it there was for
instance a lady who was well known for
her stupid prejudices and her stubborn
resistance to reasoned argument one
could have argued with her all night to
no effect she would have taken not the
slightest notice the dreams however took
a different line of approach one night
she dreamed she was attending an
important social occasion she was
greeted by the hostess with the words
how nice that you could come all your
friends are here and they are waiting
for you
the hostess then led her to the door and
opened it and the dreamer stepped
through into a cowshed this dream
language was simple enough to be
understood even by a blockhead the woman
would not at first admit the point of a
dream that struck so directly at her
self-importance but its message
nevertheless went home and after a time
she had to accept it because she could
not help seeing the self-inflicted joke
such messages from the unconscious are
of greater importance than most people
realize in our conscious life we are
exposed to all kinds of influences other
people stimulate our depresses events at
the office or in our social life
distract us such things seduce us in the
following ways that are unsuitable to
our
individuality whether or not we are
aware of the effect they have on our
consciousness it is disturbed by and
exposed to them almost without defense
this is especially the case with a
person who's extroverted attitude of
mind lays all the emphasis upon external
objects or who harbors feelings of
inferiority and doubt concerning his own
innermost personality the more that
consciousness is influenced by
prejudices errors fantasies and
infantile wishes the more the already
existing gap will widen into a neurotic
dissociation and lead to a more or less
artificial life far removed from healthy
instincts nature and truth the general
function of Dreams is to try to restore
our psychological balance by producing
dream material that reestablishes in a
subtle way
the total psychic equilibrium that is
what I call the complementary or
compensatory role of Dreams in our
psychic makeup it explains why people
who have unrealistic ideas or too high
an opinion of themselves or who make
grandiose plans out of proportion to
their real capacities have dreams of
flying or falling the dream compensates
for the deficiencies of their
personality and at the same time it
warns them of the dangers in their
present course if the warnings of the
dream are disregarded real accidents may
take their place the victim may fall
downstairs or may have a motor accident
I remember the case of a man who was
inextricably involved in a number of
shady Affairs he developed an almost
morbid passion for dangerous mountain
climbing as a sort of compensation he
was seeking to get above himself in a
dream one night he saw himself stepping
off the summit of a high mountain into
empty space when he told me his dream I
instantly saw his danger and tried to
emphasize the warning and persuade him
to restrain himself I even told him that
the dream foreshadows his death in a
mountain accident it was in vain
six months later he stepped off into
space a mountain guide watched him and a
friend letting themselves down on a rope
in a
place the friend had found a temporary
foothold on a Ledge and the dreamer was
following him down suddenly he let go of
the rope according to the guide as if he
were jumping into the air he fell upon
his friend and both went down and were
killed end of side one to continue turn
the cassette over oooh man and his
symbols by Carl G Jung continuing with
approaching the unconscious on page
fifty another typical case was that of a
lady who was living above herself she
was high and mighty in her daily life
but she had shocking dreams reminding
her of all sorts of unsavory things when
I discovered them she indignantly
refused to acknowledge them the dreams
then became menacing and full of
references to the walk she used to take
by herself in the woods where she
indulged in soulful fantasies I saw her
danger but she would not listen to my
many warnings soon afterwards she was
savagely attacked in the woods by a
sexual pervert but for the intervention
of some people who heard her screams she
would have been killed there was no
magic in this what her dreams had told
me was that this woman had a secret
longing for such an adventure just as
the mountain climber unconsciously
sought the satisfaction of finding a
definite way out of his difficulties
obviously neither of them expected the
stiff price involved she had several
bones broken and he paid with his life
thus dreams may sometimes announce
certain situations long before they
actually happen this is not necessarily
a miracle or a form of precognition many
crises in our lives have a long
unconscious history we move toward them
step by step unaware of the dangers that
are accumulating but what we consciously
failed to see is frequently perceived by
our unconscious which can pass the
information on through dreams dreams may
often warn us in this way but just as
often it seems they do not therefore any
assumption of a benevolent hand
restraining us in time is dubious or to
state it more posit
it seems that a benevolent agency is
sometimes at work and sometimes not the
mysterious hand may even point the way
to Perdition dreams sometimes proved to
be trap store fear to be so they
sometimes behave like the Delphic Oracle
that told King Croesus that if he
crossed the haleyss River he would
destroy a large Kingdom it was only
after he had been completely defeated in
battle after the crossing that he
discovered that the kingdom meant by the
Oracle was his own one cannot afford to
be naive in dealing with dreams they
originate in a spirit that is not quite
human but is rather a breath of nature a
spirit of the beautiful and generous as
well as of the cruel goddess if we want
to characterize this spirit which will
certainly get closer to it in the sphere
of ancient mythologies or the fables of
the primeval forest than in the
consciousness of modern man I am NOT
denying that great gains have resulted
from the evolution of civilized society
but these gains have been made at the
price of enormous losses whose extent we
have scarcely begun to estimate part of
the purpose of my comparisons between
the primitive and the civilized states
of man has been to show the balance of
these losses and gains primitive man was
much more governed by his instincts than
are his rational modern descendants who
have learned to control themselves in
this civilizing process we have
increasingly divided our consciousness
from the deeper instinctive strata of
the human psyche and even ultimately
from the somatic basis of the psychic
phenomenon fortunately we have not lost
these basic instinctive strata they
remain part of the unconscious even
though they may express themselves only
in the form of dream images these
instinctive phenomena one may not
incidentally always recognize them for
what they are for their character is
symbolic play a vital part in what I
have called the compensating function of
dreams for the sake of mental stability
and even physiological health the
unconscious and the conscious must be
integrally connected and thus move on
parallel lines if they are split apart
or dissociated psychological disturbance
far
in this respect dream symbols are the
essential message carriers from the
instinctive to the rational parts of the
human mind and their interpretation
enriches the poverty of consciousness so
that it learns to understand again the
forgotten language of the instinct of
course people are bound to query this
function since its symbols so often pass
unnoticed or untap rehand 'add in normal
life the understanding of dreams is
often considered superfluous I can
illustrate this by my experience with a
primitive tribe in East Africa to my
amazement these tribesmen denied that
they had any dreams but through patient
indirect talks with them I soon found
that they had dreams just like everyone
else but that they were convinced their
dreams had no meaning dreams of ordinary
men mean nothing they told me they
thought that the only dreams that
mattered were those of Chiefs and
medicine men these which concerned the
welfare of the tribe were highly
appreciated
the only drawback was that the chief and
the medicine man both claimed that they
had ceased having meaningful dreams they
dated this change from the time that the
British came to their country the
district commissioner the British
official in charge of them had taken
over the function of the great dreams
that had hitherto guided the tribes
behavior when these tribesmen conceded
that they did have dreams but thought
the meaningless they were like the
modern man who thinks that a dream has
no significance for him simply because
he does not understand it but even a
civilized man can sometimes observe that
a dream which he may not even remember
can alter his mood for better or worse
the dream has been comprehended but only
in a subliminal way and that is what
usually happens it is only on the rare
occasions when a dream is particularly
impressive for repeats itself at regular
intervals that most people consider an
interpretation desirable here I ought to
add a word of warning against
unintelligent or incompetent dream
analysis there are some people whose
mental condition is so unbalanced that
the interpretation of their dreams can
be extremely risky in such a case a very
one sided consciousness is cut off from
a correspondingly irrational or crazy
unconscious and the two should not be
brought together without taking special
precautions and speaking more generally
it is plain foolishness to believe in
ready-made systematic guides to dream
interpretation as if one could simply
buy a reference book and look up a
particular symbol no dream symbol can be
separated from the individual who dreams
it and there is no definite or
straightforward interpretation of any
dream each individual varies so much in
the way that his unconscious compliments
or compensates his conscious mind that
it is impossible to be sure how far
dreams and their symbols can be
classified at all
it is true that there are dreams and
single symbols I should prefer to call
them motifs that are typical and often
occur among such motifs are falling
flying being persecuted by dangerous
animals or hostile men being
insufficiently or absurdly closed in
public places being in a hurry or lost
in a milling crowd fighting with useless
weapons or being wholly defenseless
running hard yet getting nowhere
a typical infantile motif is the dream
of growing infinitely small or
infinitely big or being transformed from
one to the other as you find it for
instance in Lewis Carroll's Alice in
Wonderland but I must stress again that
these are motifs that must be considered
in the context of the dream itself not
as self explanatory ciphers the
recurring dream is a noteworthy
phenomenon there are cases in which
people have greened the same dream from
childhood into the later years of adult
life a dream of this kind is usually an
attempt to compensate for a particular
defect in the dreamers attitude to life
or it may date from a traumatic moment
that is left behind some specific
prejudice it may also sometimes
anticipate a future event of importance
I myself dreamed of a motif over several
years in which I would discover a part
of my house that I did not know existed
sometimes it was the quarters where my
long dead parents lived in which my
father to my surprise had a laboratory
where he studied the comparative
anatomy of fish and my mother ran a
hotel for ghostly visitors usually this
unfamiliar guest wing was an ancient
historical building long forgotten yet
my inherited property
it contained interesting antique
furniture and toward the end of this
series of Dreams I discovered an old
library whose books were unknown to me
finally in the last dream I opened one
of the books and found in it a profusion
of the most marvellous symbolic pictures
when I awoke my heart was palpitating
with excitement sometime before I had
this particular last dream of the series
I had placed an order with an
antiquarian bookseller for one of the
classic compilations of medieval
alchemists I had found the quotation in
literature that I thought might have
some connection with early byzantine
alchemy and I wished to check it several
weeks after I had had the dream of the
unknown book a parcel arrived from the
bookseller inside was a parchment volume
dating from the 16th century it was
illustrated by fascinating symbolic
pictures that instantly reminded me of
those I had seen in my dream as the
rediscovery of the principles of alchemy
came to be an important part of my work
as a pioneer of psychology the motif of
my recurring dream can easily be
understood the house of course was a
symbol of my personality and it's
conscious field of interests and the
unknown AMEX represented the
anticipation of a new field of interest
and research of which my conscious mind
was at that time unaware from that
moment thirty years ago I never had the
dream again the analysis of dreams I
began this essay by noting the
difference between a sign and a symbol
the sign is always less than the concept
it represents while a symbol always
stands for something more than its
obvious and immediate meaning symbols
moreover are natural and spontaneous
products no genius has ever sat down
with a pen or a brush in his hand and
said now I am going to invent a symbol
no one can take a more or less rational
thought reached as a
conclusion or by deliberate intent and
then give it symbolic form no matter
what fantastic trapping this one may put
upon an idea of this kind it will still
remain a sign linked to the conscious
thought behind it not a symbol that
hints at something not yet known in
dreams symbols occurs spontaneously for
dreams happen and they're not invented
they are therefore the main source of
all our knowledge about symbolism but
symbols I must point out do not occur
solely in dreams they appear in all
kinds of psychic manifestations there
are symbolic thoughts and feelings
symbolic acts and situations it often
seems that even inanimate objects
cooperate with the unconscious in the
arrangement of symbolic patterns
there are numerous well authenticated
stories of clocks stopping at the moment
of their owners death
one was the pendulum clock in the palace
of Frederick the great at south Lucy
which stopped when the King died other
common examples are those of a mirror
that breaks or a picture that falls when
the death occurs or minor but
unexplained breakages in a house where
someone is passing through an emotional
crisis even if skeptics refused to
credit such reports stories of this kind
are always cropping up and this alone
should serve as ample proof of their
psychological importance there are many
symbols however among them the most
important that are not individual but
collective in their nature and origin
these are chiefly religious images the
believer assumes that they are of divine
origin that they have been revealed to
man the skeptic says flatly that they
have been invented both are wrong it is
true as the skeptic notes that religious
symbols and concepts have for centuries
been the object of careful and quite
conscious elaboration it is equally true
as the believer implies that their
origin is so far buried in the mystery
of the past that they seem to have no
human source but they are in fact
collective representations emanating
from primeval dreams and creative
fantasies as such these images are
involuntary spontaneous manifestations
and by no means intentional inventions
this fact as I shall later explain as a
direct and important bearing upon the
interpretation of dreams it is obvious
that if you assume the dream to be
symbolic you will interpret it
differently from a person who believes
that the essential energizing thought or
emotion is known already and is merely
disguised by the dream in the latter
case dream interpretation makes a little
sense for you find only what you already
know it is for this reason that I have
always said to my pupils learn as much
as you can about symbolism then forget
it all when you were analyzing a dream
this advice is of such practical
importance that I have made it a rule to
remind myself that I can never
understand somebody else's dream well
enough to interpret it correctly I have
done this in order to check the flow of
my own associations and reactions which
might otherwise prevail over my patients
uncertainties and hesitations as it is
of the greatest therapeutic importance
for an analyst to get the particulars of
a dream that is the contribution that
the unconscious is making to the
conscious mind as accurately as possible
it is essential for him to explore the
content of a dream with the utmost
thoroughness I had a dream when I was
working with Freud that illustrates this
point I dreamed that I was in my home
apparently on the first floor in a cozy
Pleasant sitting room for initiative the
manor of the 18th century I was
astonished that I had never seen this
room before and began to wonder what the
ground floor was like I went downstairs
and found the place was rather dark with
paneled walls and heavy furniture dating
from the 16th century or even earlier my
surprise and curiosity increased I
wanted to see more of the whole
structure of this house so I went down
to the cellar where I found a door
opening onto a flight of stone steps
that led to a large vaulted room the
floor consisted of large slabs of stone
and the walls seemed very ancient I
examined the mortar and found it was
mixed with splinters of brick obviously
the walls were of Roman origin
I became increasingly excited in one
corner I saw an iron ring on a stone
slab I pulled up the slab and saw yet
another narrow flight of steps leading
to a kind of cave which seemed to be a
prehistoric tomb containing two skulls
some bones and broken shards of pottery
then I woke up
if Freud when he analyzed this dream had
followed my method of exploring its
specific associations and context he
would have heard a far-reaching story
but I am afraid he would have dismissed
it as a mere effort to escape from a
problem that was really his own the
dream is in fact a short summary of my
life more specifically of the
development of my mind I grew up in a
house 200 years old
our furniture consisted mostly of pieces
about 300 years old and mentally my
hitherto greatest spiritual adventure
had been to study the philosophies of
Compton tripping Hauer
the great news of the day it was the
work of Charles Darwin shortly before
this I had been living with distilled
medieval concepts of my parents for whom
the world and men were still presided
over by divine omnipotence and
Providence this world had become
antiquated and obsolete my Christian
faith had become relative through its
encounter with Eastern religions and
Greek philosophy it is for this reason
that the ground floor was so still dark
and obviously uninhabited my then
historical interests had developed from
an original preoccupation with
comparative anatomy and paleontology
while I was working as an assistant at
the anatomical Institute I was
fascinated by the bones of fossil men
particularly by the much-discussed
neanderthalensis and the still more
controversial skull of Dubois hit the
canvas as a matter of fact these were my
real associations to the dream but I did
not dare to mention the subject of
skulls skeletons or corpses to Freud
because I had learned that this theme
was not popular with him he cherished
the peculiar idea that I anticipated his
early death and he drew this conclusion
from the fact that I had shown much
interest in the mummified corpses in the
so
called Bly Keller in Bremen which we
visited together in nineteen nine on our
way to take the boat to America
thus I felt reluctant to come out with
my own thoughts since through recent
experience I was deeply impressed by the
almost unbridgeable gap between Freud's
mental outlook and background and my own
I was afraid of losing his friendship if
I should open up to him about my own
inner world which I surmised would look
very queer to him feeling quite
uncertain about my own psychology I
almost automatically told him a lie
about my free positions in order to
escape the impossible task of
enlightening him about my very personal
and utterly different Constitution I
must apologize for this rather lengthy
narration of the jam I got into through
telling Freud my dream but it is a good
example of the difficulties in which one
gets involved in the course of a real
dream analysis so much depends upon the
personal differences between the analyst
and the analyzed I soon realized that
Freud was looking for some incompatible
wish of mine and so I suggested
tentatively that the skulls I had
dreamed of might refer to certain
members of my family whose death for
some reason I might desire this proposal
met with his approval but I was not
satisfied with such a funny solution
while I was trying to find a suitable
answer to Freud's questions I was
suddenly confused by an intuition about
the role that the subjective factor
plays in psychological understanding my
intuition was so overwhelming that I
thought only of how to get out of this
impossible snarl and I took the easy way
out by a lie this was neither elegant
nor morally defensible but otherwise I
should have risked a fatal row with
Freud and I did not feel up to that for
many reasons my intuition consisted of
the sudden and most unexpected insight
into the fact that my dream meant myself
my life and my world my whole reality
against the theoretical structure
erected by another strange mind for
reasons and purposes of its own it was
not Freud's dream it was mine and I
understood suddenly in a flash what my
dream meant this conflict illustrates a
vital point about dream analysis it is
not so much a technique
that can be learned and applied
according to the rules as it is a
dialectical exchange between two
personalities if it is handled as a
mechanical technique the individual
psychic personality of the dreamer gets
lost and the therapeutic problem is
reduced to the simple question which of
the two people concerned the analyst or
the dreamer will dominate the other I
gave up hypnotic treatment for this very
reason because I did not want to impose
my will on others
I wanted the healing processes to grow
out of the patient's own personality not
from suggestions by me that would have
only a passing effect my aim was to
protect and preserve my patient's
dignity and freedom so that he could
live his life according to his own
wishes in this exchange with Freud it
dawned on me for the first time that
before we construct general theories
about man and his psyche we should learn
a lot more about the real human being we
have to deal with the individual is the
only reality the further we move away
from the individual toward abstract
ideas about Homo sapiens the more likely
we are to fall into error in these times
of social upheaval and rapid change it
is desirable to know much more than we
do about the individual human being for
so much depends upon his mental and
moral qualities but if we are to see
things in their right perspective we
need to understand the past of man as
well as his present that is why an
understanding of myths and symbols is of
essential importance the problem of
types in all other branches of science
it is legitimate to apply a hypothesis
to an impersonal subject psychology
however inescapably confronts you with
the living relations between two
individuals neither of whom can be
divested of his subjective personality
nor indeed depersonalized in any other
way the analyst and his patient may set
out by a greeting to deal with a chosen
problem in an impersonal and objective
manner but once they are engaged their
whole personalities are involved in
their discussion at this point further
progress is possible only if mutual
agreement can be
can we make any sort of objective
judgment about the final result only if
we make a comparison between our
conclusions and the standards that are
generally valid in the social media to
which the individuals belong even then
we must take into account the mental
equilibrium or sanity of the individual
concerned but the result cannot be a
completely collective leveling out of
the individual to adjust him to the
norms of his society this would amount
to a most unnatural condition a sane and
normal society is one in which people
habitually disagree because general
agreement is relatively rare outside the
sphere of instinctive human qualities
this Agreement functions as a vehicle of
mental life in society but it is not a
goal agreement is equally important
because psychology basically depends
upon balanced opposites no judgment can
be considered to be final in which its
reversibility has not been taken into
account the reason for this
peculiarities lies in the fact that
there is no standpoint above or outside
psychology that would enable us to form
an ultimate judgment of what the psyche
is in spite of the fact that dreams
demand individual treatment some
generalities are necessary in order to
classify and clarify the material that
the psychologist collects by studying
many individuals it would obviously be
impossible to formulate any
psychological theory or to teach it by
describing large numbers of separate
cases without any effort to see what
they have in common and how they differ
any general characteristic can be chosen
as a basis one can for instance make a
relatively simple distinction between
individuals who have extroverted
personalities and others who are
introverted this is only one of many
possible generalizations but it enables
one to see immediately the difficulties
that can arise if the analyst should
happen to be one type and is patient the
other since any deeper analysis of
dreams leads to the confrontation of two
individuals it will obviously make a
great difference whether their types of
attitude are the same or not
if both belong to the same type they may
sail along happily for a long
I'm but if one is an extrovert and the
other an introvert they're different and
contradictory stand points may clash
right away particularly when they are
unaware of their own type of personality
or when they are convinced that their
own is the only right type the extrovert
for instance will choose the majority
view the introvert will reject it simply
because it is fashionable such a
misunderstanding is easy enough because
the value of the one is the non value of
the other Freud himself for instance
interpreted the introverted type is an
individual morbidly concerned with
himself but introspection and
self-knowledge can just as well be of
the greatest value and importance it is
vitally necessary to take account of
such differences of personality in dream
interpretation it cannot be assumed that
the analyst is a super man who is above
such differences just because he is a
doctor who has acquired a psychological
theory and the corresponding technique
he can only imagine himself to be
superior insofar as he assumes that his
theory and technique are absolute truths
capable of embracing the whole of the
human psyche since such an assumption is
more than doubtful he cannot really be
sure of it
consequently he will be assailed by
secret doubts if he confronts the human
wholeness of his patient with a theory
or technique which is merely a
hypothesis or an attempt instead of with
his own living wholeness the analyst
Tolle personality is the only adequate
equivalent of his patients personality
psychological experience and knowledge
do not amount to more than mere
advantages on the side of the analyst
they do not keep him outside the fray in
which he is bound to be tested just as
much as his patient thus it matters a
good deal whether their personalities
are harmonious in conflict or
complimentary extraversion and
introversion are just two among many
peculiarities of human behavior but they
are often rather obvious and easily
recognizable if one studies extroverted
individuals for instance one soon
discovers that they differ in many ways
from one another and that being
extroverted is therefore a superficial
and two general criterion to be
characteristic that is why long ago I
tried to find some further basic
peculiarities peculiarities that might
serve the purpose of giving some order
to the apparently limitless variations
in human individuality
I had always been impressed by the fact
that there are a surprising number of
individuals who never use their minds if
they can avoid it and an equal number
who do use their minds but in an
amazingly stupid way I was also
surprised to find many intelligent and
wide-awake people who lived as far as
one could make out as if they had never
learned to use their sense organs they
did not see the things before their eyes
hear the word sounding in their ears or
notice the things they touched or tasted
some lived without being aware of the
state of their own bodies there were
others who seemed to live in a most
curious condition of consciousness as if
the state they had arrived at today were
final with no possibility of change or
as if the world and the psyche were
static and would remain so forever
they seemed devoid of all imagination
and they entirely and exclusively
depended upon their sense perception
chances and possibilities did not exist
in their world and in today there was no
real tomorrow the future was just the
repetition of the past
I am trying here to give the reader a
glimpse of my own first impressions when
I began to observe the many people I met
it soon became clear to me however that
the people who used their minds were
those who thought that is who applied
their intellectual faculty in trying to
adapt themselves to people and
circumstances and the equally
intelligent people who did not think
were those who sought and found their
way by feeling feeling is a word that
needs some explanation for instance one
speaks of feeling when it is a matter of
sentiment corresponding to the French
term saltymom but one also applies the
same word to define an opinion for
example a communication from the White
House may begin the president feels
furthermore the word may be used to
express an intuition I had a feeling as
if when I used the word
in contrast to thinking I refer to a
judgment of value for instance agreeable
or disagreeable good or bad and so on
feeling according to this definition is
not an emotion which as the word conveys
is involuntary feeling as I mean it is
like thinking irrational that is
ordering function whereas intuition is
an irrational that is perceiving
function insofar as intuition is a hunch
it is not the product of a voluntary act
it is rather an involuntary event which
depends upon different external or
internal circumstances instead of an act
of judgment intuition is more like a
sense perception which is also an
irrational event insofar as it depends
essentially upon objective stimuli which
oh their existence to physical and not
to mental causes these four functional
types correspond to the obvious means by
which consciousness obtains its
orientation to experience sensation that
is sense perception tells you that
something exists thinking tells you what
it is feeling tells you whether it is
agreeable or not and intuition tells you
whence it comes and where it is going
the reader should understand that these
four criteria of types of human behavior
are just four viewpoints among many
others like rope our temperament
imagination memory and so on
there is nothing dogmatic about them but
their basic nature recommends them as
suitable criteria for a classification I
find them particularly helpful when I am
called upon to explain parents to
children and husbands to wives and vice
versa they are also useful in
understanding one's own prejudices thus
if you want to understand another
person's dream you have to sacrifice
your own predilections and suppress your
prejudices this is not easy or
comfortable because it means a moral
effort that is not to everyone's taste
but if the analyst does not make the
effort to criticize his own standpoint
and to admit its relativity he will get
neither the right information about nor
sufficient insight into his patient's
mind the analyst expects at least a
certain willingness on the patient's
part to listen to his opinion and
take it seriously and the patient must
be granted the same right although such
a relationship is indispensable for any
understanding and is therefore of
self-evident necessity one must remind
oneself again and again that it is more
important in therapy for the patient to
understand than for the analysts
theoretical expectations to be satisfied
the patient's resistance to the analysts
interpretation is not necessarily wrong
it is rather a sure sign that something
does not click either the patient has
not yet reached the point where he
understands or the interpretation does
not fit in our efforts to interpret the
dream symbols of another person we are
almost invariably hampered by our
tendency to fill in the unavoidable gaps
in our understanding by projection that
is by the assumption that what the
analyst perceives or thinks is equally
perceived or thought by the dreamer to
overcome this source of error
I have always insisted on the importance
of sticking to the context of the
particular dream and excluding all
theoretical assumptions about dreams in
general except for the hypothesis that
dreams in some way makes sense it will
be clear from all I have said that we
cannot lay down general rules for
interpreting dreams when I suggested
earlier that the overall function of
dreams seems to be to compensate for
deficiencies or distortions in the
conscious mind
I meant that this assumption opened up
the most promising approach to the
nature of particular dreams in some
cases you can see this function plainly
demonstrated one of my patients had a
very high opinion of himself and was
unaware that almost everyone who knew
him was irritated by his error of moral
superiority he came to me with a dream
in which he had seen a drunken [ __ ]
rolling in a ditch a sight that evoked
from him only the patronizing comment
it's terrible to see how low a man can
fall it was evident the unpleasant
nature of the dream was at least in part
an attempt to offset his inflated
opinion of his own merits but there was
something more to it than this it turned
out that he had a brother who was a
degenerate alcoholic but the dream also
revealed was that his superior attitude
was compensating the brother as both an
outer and an inner figure in another
case I recall a woman who was proud of
her intelligent understanding of
psychology had recurring dreams about
another woman when in ordinary life she
met this woman she did not like her
thinking her a vain and dishonest
intriguer but in the dreams the woman
appeared almost as a sister friendly and
likeable my patient could not understand
why she should dream so favorably about
a person she disliked but these dreams
were trying to convey the idea that she
herself was shadowed by an unconscious
character that resembled the other woman
it was hard for my patient who had very
clear ideas about her own personality to
realize that the dream was telling her
about her own power complex and her
hidden motivations unconscious
influences that had more than once led
to disagreeable rouse with her friends
she had always blamed others for these
not herself it is not merely the shadow
side of our personalities that we
overlook disregard and repress we may
also do the same to our positive
qualities an example that comes to mind
is that of an apparently modest and
self-effacing man with charming manners
he always seemed content with a back
seat but discreetly insisted on being
present when asked to speak he would
offer a well-informed opinion though he
never intruded it but he sometimes
hinted that a given matter could be
dealt with in a far superior way at a
certain higher level though he never
explained how in his dreams however he
constantly had encounters with great
historical figures such as Napoleon and
Alexander the Great these dreams were
clearly compensating for an inferiority
complex but they had another implication
what sort of man must I be the dream was
asking to have such illustrious callers
in this respect the dream was pointed to
a secret megalomania which offset the
dreamers feeling of inferiority this
unconscious idea of grandeur insulated
him from the reality of his environment
and enabled him to remain aloof from
obligation
that would be imperative for other
people he felt no need to prove either
to himself or to others that his
superior judgment was based on superior
merit he was in fact unconsciously
playing an insane game and the dreams
were seeking to bring it to the level of
consciousness in a curiously ambiguous
way hobnobbing with Napoleon and being
on speaking terms with Alexander the
Great are exactly the kind of fantasies
produced by an inferiority complex
but why one asks could not the dream the
open and direct about it and say what it
had to say without ambiguity I have
frequently been asked this question and
I have asked it myself I am often
surprised at the tantalizing way dreams
seemed to evade definite information or
omit the decisive point freud assumed
the existence of a special function of
the psyche which he called the sensor
this he supposed twisted the dream
images and made them unrecognizable or
misleading in order to deceive the
dreaming consciousness about the real
subject of the dream by concealing the
critical thought from the dreamer the
sensor protected his sleep against the
shock of a disagreeable reminiscence but
I am skeptical about the theory that the
dream is a guardian of sleep dreams just
as often disturbed sleep it rather looks
as if the approach to consciousness has
a blocking out effect upon the
subliminal contents of the psyche the
subliminal state retains ideas and
images at a much lower level of tension
than they possess in consciousness in
the subliminal condition they lose
clarity of definition the relations
between them are less consequential and
more vaguely analogous less rational and
therefore more incomprehensible this can
also be observed in all dreamlike
conditions whether due to fatigue fever
or toxins but if something happens to
endow any of these images with greater
tension they become less subliminal and
as they come close to the threshold of
consciousness more sharply defined it is
from this fact that one may understand
why dreams often express themselves as
analogies why one dream image slides
into another and why neither the logic
nor the time
scale of our waking life seems to apply
the form that dreams take is natural to
the unconscious because the material
from which they are produced is retained
in the subliminal state in precisely
this fashion dreams do not guard sleep
from what Freud called the incompatible
wish what he called disguise is actually
the shape all impulses naturally take in
the unconscious
thus a dream cannot produce a definite
thought if it begins to do so it ceases
to be a dream because it crosses the
threshold of consciousness that is why
dreams seem to skip the very points that
are most important to the conscious mind
and seem rather to manifest the fringe
of consciousness like the faint gleam of
stars during a total eclipse of the Sun
we should understand that dream symbols
are for the most part manifestations of
a psyche that is beyond the control of
the conscious mind meaning and
purposefulness are not the prerogatives
of the mind they operate in the whole of
living nature there is no difference in
principle between organic and psychic
growth as a plant produces its flower so
the psyche creates its symbols every
dream is evidence of this process so by
means of dreams plus all sorts of
intuitions impulses and other
spontaneous events instinctive forces
influence the activity of consciousness
whether that influences for better or
for worse depends upon the actual
contents of the unconscious if it
contains too many things that normally
ought to be conscious then its function
becomes twisted and prejudiced motives
appear that are not based upon true
instincts but that oh their existence
and psychic importance to the fact that
they have been consigned to the
unconscious by repression or neglect
they overlay as it were the normal
unconscious psyche and distort its
natural tendency to express basic
symbols and motifs
therefore it is reasonable for a
psychoanalyst concerned with the causes
of a mental disturbance to begin by
eliciting from his patient or more or
less voluntary confession and
realization of everything that the
patient dislikes or fears this is like
the much older confession
of the church which in many ways
anticipated modern psychological
techniques at least this is the general
rule in practice however it may work the
other way round
overpowering feelings of inferiority or
serious weakness may make it very
difficult even impossible for the
patient to face fresh evidence of his
own inadequacy so I have often found it
profitable to begin by giving a positive
outlook to the patient this provides a
helpful sense of security when he
approaches the more painful insights
take as an example a dream of personal
exaltation in which for instance one has
tea with the Queen of England or finds
oneself on intimate terms with the Pope
if the dreamer is not a schizophrenic
the practical interpretation of the
symbol depends very much upon his
present state of mind that is the
condition of his ego if the dreamer
overestimates his own value it is easy
to show from the material produced by
association of ideas how inappropriate
and childish the dreamers intentions are
and how much they emanate from childish
wishes to be equal to or superior to his
parents but if it is a case of
inferiority where an all-pervading
feeling of worthlessness has already
overcome every positive aspect of the
dreamers personality it would be quite
wrong to depress him still more by
showing how infantile ridiculous or even
perverse he is that would cruelly
increase his inferiority as well as
caused an unwelcome and quite
unnecessary resistance to the treatment
there is no therapeutic technique or a
doctrine that is of general application
since every case that one receives for
treatment is an individual in a specific
condition I remember a patient I once
had to treat over a period of nine years
I saw him only for a few weeks each year
since he lived abroad from the start I
knew what his real trouble was but I
also saw that the least attempt to get
close to the truth was met by a violent
defensive reaction that threatened a
complete rupture between us whether I
liked it or not I had to do my best to
maintain our relation and to follow his
inclination which was supported by his
dreams and which led our discussion
from the root of his neurosis we ranged
so widely that I often accused myself of
leading my patient astray nothing but
the fact that his condition slowly but
clearly improved prevented me from
confronting him brutally with the truth
in the tenth year however the patient
declared himself to be cured and freed
from all his symptoms I was surprised
because theoretically his condition was
incurable noticing my astonishment he
smiled and said in effect and I want to
thank you above all for your unfailing
tact and patience in helping me to
circumvent the painful cause of my
neurosis I am now ready to tell you
everything about it if I had been able
to talk freely about it I would have
told you what it was at my first
consultation but that would have
destroyed my rapport with you where
should I have been then I should have
been morally bankrupt in the course of
ten years I have learned to trust you
and as my confidence grew my condition
improved I improved because this slow
process restored my belief in myself now
I am strong enough to discuss the
problem that was destroying me he then
made a devastatingly frank confession of
his problem which showed me the reasons
for the peculiar course our treatment
had had to follow the original shock had
been such that alone he had been unable
to face it he needed the help of another
and the therapeutic task was the slow
establishment of confidence rather than
the demonstration of a clinical theory
from cases like this I learned to adapt
my methods to the needs of the
individual patient rather than to commit
myself to general theoretical
considerations that might be
inapplicable in any particular case the
knowledge of human nature that I have
accumulated in the course of 60 years of
practical experience has taught me to
consider each case as a new one in which
first of all I have had to seek the
individual approach sometimes I have not
hesitated to plunge into a careful study
of infantile events and fantasies at
other times I have begun at the top even
if this has meant soaring straight into
the most remote metaphysical
speculations it all depends on learning
the language of the individual
patient and following the gropings of
his unconscious toward the light some
cases demand one method and some another
this is especially true when one seeks
to interpret symbols to different
individuals may have almost exactly the
same dream this as one soon discovers in
clinical experience is less uncommon
than the layman may think yet if for
instance one dreamer is young and the
other old the problem that disturbs them
is correspondingly different and it
would be obviously absurd to interpret
both dreams in the same way an example
that comes to my mind is a dream in
which a group of young men are riding on
horseback across a wide field the
dreamer is in the lead and he jumps a
ditch full of water just clearing in
this hazard the rest of the party fall
into the ditch now the young man who
first told me this dream was a cautious
introverted type but I also heard the
same dream from an old man of daring
character who had lived an active and
enterprising life at the time he had
this dream he was an invalid who gave
his doctor and nurse a great deal of
trouble he had actually injured himself
by his disobedience of medical
instructions it was clear to me that
this dream was telling the young man
what he ought to do but it was telling
the old man what he actually was still
doing whereas it encouraged the hesitant
young man the old man was in no such
need of encouragement the spirit of
enterprise that still flickered within
him was indeed his greatest trouble this
example shows how the interpretation of
dreams and symbols largely depends upon
the individual circumstances of the
dreamer and the condition of his mind
the archetype in dream symbolism I have
already suggested the dream served the
purpose of compensation this assumption
means that the dream is a normal psychic
phenomenon that transmits unconscious
reactions or spontaneous impulses to
consciousness many dreams can be
interpreted with the help of the dreamer
who provides both the association's to
and the context of the dream image by
means of which one can look at all its
aspects
this method is adequate in all ordinary
case
such as those when a relative a friend
or a patient tells you would dream more
or less in the course of conversation
but when it is a matter of obsessive
dreaming or of highly emotional dreams
the personal associations produced by
the dreamer do not usually suffice for a
satisfactory interpretation in such
cases we have to take into consideration
the fact first observed and commented on
by Freud that elements often occur in a
dream that are not individual and that
cannot be derived from the dreamers
personal experience these elements as I
have previously mentioned are what Freud
called archaic remnants mental forms
whose presence cannot be explained by
anything in the individual's own life
and which seemed to be Aboriginal innate
and inherited shapes of the human mind
just as the human body represents a
whole Museum of organs each with a long
evolutionary history behind it so we
should expect to find that the mind is
organized in a similar way it can no
more be a product without history than
is the body in which it exists by
history I do not mean the fact that the
mind builds itself up by conscious
reference to the past through language
and other cultural traditions I am
referring to the biological prehistoric
and unconscious development of the mind
in archaic man whose psyche was still
close to that of the animal this
immensely old psyche forms the basis of
our mind just as much as the structure
of our body is based on the general
anatomical pattern of the mammal the
trained eye of the anatomist or the
biologist finds many traces of this
original pattern in our bodies the
experienced investigator of the mind can
similarly see the analogies between the
dream pictures of modern man and the
products of the primitive mind its
collective images and its mythological
motifs just as the biologist needs the
science of comparative anatomy however
the psychologist cannot do without a
comparative anatomy of the psyche in
practice to put it differently the
psychologists must have a sufficient
experience not only of dreams and other
products of unconscious activity but
also of mythology in its widest sense
without this equipment
nobody can spot the important analogies
it is not possible for instance to see
the analogy between a case of compulsion
neurosis and that of a classical demonic
possession without a working knowledge
of both my views about the archaic
remnants which I call archetypes or
primordial images have been constantly
criticized by people who lack a
sufficient knowledge of the psychology
of dreams and of mythology the term
archetype is often misunderstood as
meaning certain definite mythological
images or motifs but these are nothing
more than conscious representations it
would be absurd to assume that such a
variable representations could be
inherited the archetype is a tendency to
form such representations of a motif
representations that can vary a great
deal in detail without losing their
basic pattern there are for instance
many representations of the motif of the
hostile brethren but the motif itself
remains the same my critics have
incorrectly assumed that I am dealing
with inherited representations and on
that ground they have dismissed the idea
of the archetype as mere superstition
they have failed to take into account
the fact that if archetypes were
representations that originated in our
consciousness or were acquired by
consciousness we should surely
understand them and not be bewildered
and astonished when they present
themselves in our consciousness they are
indeed an instinctive trend as marked in
the impulse of birds to build nests or
ants to form organized colonies here I
must clarify the relation between
instincts and archetypes what we
properly call instincts are
physiological urges and are perceived by
the senses but at the same time they
also manifest themselves in fantasies
and often reveal their presence only by
symbolic images these manifestations are
what I call the archetypes they are
without known origin and they reproduce
themselves in any time or in any part of
the world even where transmission by
direct descent or cross-fertilization
through migration must be ruled out I
can remember many cases of people who
have consulted me because they were
baffled by their own
or by their children's they were at a
complete loss to understand the terms of
the dreams the reason was that the
dreams contained images that they could
not relate to anything they could
remember or could have passed on to
their children yet some of these
patients were highly educated a few of
them were actually psychiatrists
themselves I vividly recall the case of
a professor who had had a sudden vision
and thought he was insane
he came to see me in a state of complete
panic I simply took a four hundred year
old book from the shelf and showed him
an old woodcut depicting his very vision
there's no reason for you to believe
that you're insane I said to him they
knew about your vision four hundred
years ago whereupon he sat down entirely
deflated but once more normal a very
important case came to me from a man who
himself was a psychiatrist one day he
brought me a handwritten booklet he had
received as a Christmas present from his
ten-year-old daughter it contained a
whole series of dreams she had had when
she was 8 they made up the weirdest
series of dreams that I have ever seen
and I could well understand why the
father was more than just puzzled by
them though childlike they were
uncanny and they contained images whose
origin was wholly incomprehensible to
the father here are the relevant motifs
from the dreams 1 the evil animal a
snake-like monster with many horns kills
and devours all other animals but God
comes from the four corners being in
fact four separate gods and gives
rebirth to all the dead animals - an
ascent into heaven where pagan dances
are being celebrated and a descent into
Hell where angels are doing good deeds 3
a horde of small animals frightens the
dreamer the animals increased to a
tremendous size and one of them devours
the little girl for a small Mouse is
penetrated by worms
snakes fishes and human beings thus the
mouse becomes human this portrays the
four stages of the origin of mankind 5 a
drop of water is seen as it appears when
looked at through a microscope
the girl sees that the drop is full of
tree branches this portrays the origin
of the world six a bad boy has a clod of
Earth and throws bits of it at everyone
who passes in this way all the
passers-by become bad seven a drunken
woman falls into the water and comes out
renewed and sober eight the scene is in
America where many people are rolling on
an ant-heap attacked by the ants the
dreamer in a panic falls into a river 9
there is a desert on the moon where the
dreamer sinks so deeply into the ground
that she reaches hell 10 in this dream
the girl has a vision of a luminous ball
she touches it vapours emanate from it a
man comes and kills her 11 the girl
dreams she
dangerously ill suddenly birds come out
of her skin and cover her completely 12
swarms of gnats obscured the Sun the
Moon and all the stars except one that
one star falls upon the dreamer in the
unabridged German original each dream
begins with the words of the old fairy
tale once upon a time by these words the
little dreamer suggests that she feels
as if each dream were a sort of fairy
tale which she wants to tell her father
as a Christmas present the father tried
to explain the dreams in terms of their
context but he could not do so for there
seemed to be no personal associations to
them the possibility that these dreams
were conscious elaborations can of
course be ruled out only by someone who
knew the child well enough to be
absolutely sure of her truthfulness they
would however remain a challenge to our
understanding even if they were
fantasies in this case the father was
convinced that the dreams were authentic
and I have no reason to doubt it I knew
the little girl myself but this was
before she gave her dreams to her father
so that I had no chance to ask her about
them she lived abroad and died of an
infectious disease about a year after
that Christmas her dreams have a
decidedly peculiar character they're
leading thoughts are markedly
philosophic in concept the first one for
instance speaks of an evil monster
killing other animals but God gives
rebirth to them all through a divine a
packet a stasis or restitution in the
Western world this idea is known through
the Christian tradition it can be found
in the Acts of the Apostles 3:21 Christ
whom the heaven must receive until the
time of restitution of all things the
early Greek Fathers of the Church for
instance Origen particularly insisted
upon the idea that at the end of time
everything will be restored by the
Redeemer to its original and perfect
state but according to st. Matthew 17 11
there was already an old Jewish
tradition that Elias truly shall first
come and restore all things first
Corinthians 15:22 refers to the same
idea in the
blowing words for as in Adam all die
even so in Christ shall all be made
alive one might guess that the child had
encountered this thought in her
religious education but she had very
little religious background
her parents were Protestants in name but
in fact they knew the Bible only from
hearsay it is particularly unlikely that
the recondite image of Africa tast
assists had been fully explained to the
girl certainly her father had never
heard of this mythical idea nine of the
twelve dreams are influenced by the
theme of destruction and restoration and
none of these dreams shows traces of
specific Christian education or
influence on the contrary they are more
closely related to primitive myths this
relation is corroborated by the other
motif the cosmogonic myth the creation
of the world and of man that appears in
the fourth and fifth dreams the same
connection is found in first Corinthians
15:22 which I have just quoted in this
passage to Adam and Christ death and
resurrection are linked together the
general idea of Christ the Redeemer
belongs to the worldwide and pre Christ
theme of the hero and rescuer who
although he has been devoured by a
monster appears again in a miraculous
way having overcome whatever monster it
was that swallowed him when and where
such a motif originated nobody knows we
do not even know how to go about
investigating the problem the one
apparent certainty is that every
generation seems to have known it as a
tradition handed down from some
preceding time thus we can safely assume
that it originated that a period when
man did not yet know that he possessed a
hero myth in an age that is to say when
he did not yet consciously reflect on
what he was saying the hero figure is an
archetype which has existed since time
immemorial the production of archetypes
by children is especially significant
because one can sometimes be quite
certain that a child has had no direct
access to the tradition concerned in
this case the girl's family had no more
than a superficial acquaintance with the
Christian tradition Christian themes may
of course be represented by such
is God angels heaven hell and evil but
the way in which they are treated by
this child points to a totally
non-christian origin let us take the
first dream of the God who really
consists of four gods coming from the
four corners the corners of what there
is no room mentioned in the dream a room
would not even fit in with the picture
of what is obviously a cosmic event in
which the universal being Himself
intervenes the quarter natee or element
of fauna sits elf is a strange idea but
one that plays a great role in many
religions and philosophies in the
Christian religion it has been
superseded by the Trinity a notion that
we must assume was known to the child
but who in an ordinary middle-class
family of today would be likely to know
of a divine quarter natee it is an idea
that was once fairly familiar among
students of the hermetic philosophy in
the Middle Ages but it petered out with
the beginning of the 18th century and it
has been entirely obsolete for at least
200 years where then did the little girl
pick it up from Ezekiel's vision but
there is no Christian teaching that
identifies the Seraphim with God the
same question may be asked about the
horned serpent in the Bible it is true
there are many horned animals in the
book of Revelation for instance but
always seemed the quadruped head
although their overlord is the dragon
the Greek word for which dragon also
means serpent the horned serpent appears
in 16th century Latin alchemy as the
quadric or neuter serpent for Horned
serpent a symbol of mercury and an
antagonist of the Christian Trinity but
this is an obscure reference so far as I
can discover it is made by only one
author and this child had no means of
knowing it in the second dream a motif
appears that is definitely non-christian
and that contains a reversal of accepted
values for instance pagan dances by men
in heaven and good deeds by angels in
hell
this symbol suggests a relativity of
moral values where did the child find
such a revolutionary notion worthy of
Nietzsche's genius
these questions lead us to another what
is the compensatory meaning of these
dreams to which the little girl
obviously attributed so much importance
that she presented them to her father as
a Christmas present
if the dreamer had been a primitive
medicine man one could reasonably assume
that they represent variations of the
philosophical themes of death of
resurrection or restitution of the
origin of the world the creation of man
and the relativity of values but one
might give up such dreams as hopelessly
difficult if one tried to interpret them
from a personal level they undoubtedly
contain collective images and they are
in a way analogous to the doctrines
taught to young people in primitive
tribes when they are about to be
initiated as men at such times they
learn about what God or the gods or the
founding animals have done how the world
and man were created how the end of the
world will come and the meaning of death
is there any occasion when we in
Christian civilization hand out similar
instructions there is in adolescence but
many people begin to think again of
things like this in old age at the
approach of death the little girl has it
happened was in both these situations
she was approaching puberty and at the
same time the end of her life little or
nothing in the symbolism of her dreams
points to the beginning of a normal
adult life but there are many allusions
to destruction and restoration when I
first read her dreams indeed I had the
uncanny feeling that they suggested
impending disaster the reason I felt
like that was the peculiar nature of the
compensation that I deduced from the
symbolism it was the opposite of what
one would expect to find in the
consciousness of a girl of that age
these dreams open up a new and rather
terrifying aspect of life and death one
would expect to find such images in an
aging person who looks back upon life
rather than to be given them by a child
who would normally be looking forward
their atmosphere recalls the old Roman
saying life is a short dream rather than
the joy and exuberance of its springtime
for this child's life was like a ver
sacrum event
Wow of a vernal sacrifice as the Roman
poet puts it experience shows that the
unknown approach of death casts in a
D'Ambrosio an anticipatory shadow over
the life and dreams of the victim even
the altar in Christian churches
represents on the one hand a tomb and on
the other a place of resurrection the
transformation of death into eternal
life such are the ideas that the dreams
brought home to the child they were a
preparation for death expressed through
short stories like the tales told at
primitive initiations or the Coens of
Zen Buddhism this message is unlike the
Orthodox Christian doctrine and more
like ancient primitive thought it seems
to have originated outside historical
tradition in the long-forgotten psychic
sources that since prehistoric times
have nourished philosophical and
religious speculation about life and
death
It was as if future events were casting
their shadow back by arousing in the
child certain thought forms that though
normally dormant describe or accompany
the approach of a fatal issue although
the specific shape in which they express
themselves is more or less personal
their general pattern is collective they
are found everywhere and at all times
just as animal instincts vary a good
deal in the different species and yet
serve the same general purposes we do
not assume that each newborn animal
creates its own instincts as an
individual acquisition and we must not
suppose that human individuals invent
their specific human ways with every new
birth like the instinct the collective
thought patterns of the human mind are
innate and inherited they function when
the occasion arises in more or less the
same way in all of us emotional
manifestations to which such thought
patterns belong are recognisably the
same all over the earth we can identify
them even in animals and the animals
themselves understand one another in
this respect even though they may belong
to different species and what about
insects with their complicated symbiotic
functions most of them do not even know
their parents and have nobody to teach
them why should one assume then that
man is the only living being deprived of
specific instincts or that his psyche is
devoid of all traces of its evolution
naturally if you identify the psyche
with consciousness you can easily fall
into the erroneous idea that man comes
into the world with a psyche that is
empty and that in later years it
contains nothing more than what it has
learned by individual experience but the
psyche is more than consciousness
animals have little consciousness but
many impulses and reactions that denote
the existence of a psyche and primitives
to a lot of things whose meaning is
unknown to them you may ask many
civilized people in vain for the real
meaning of the Christmas tree or of the
Easter egg the fact is they do things
without knowing why they do them I am
inclined to the view that things were
generally done first and that it was
only a long time afterward that somebody
asked why they were done the medical
psychologist is constantly confronted
with otherwise intelligent patients who
behave in a peculiar and unpredictable
way and who have no inkling of what they
say or do they are suddenly caught by
unreasonable moods for which they
themselves cannot account superficially
such reactions and impulses seem to be
of an intimately personal nature and so
we dismissed them as idiosyncratic
behavior in fact they are based upon a
preformed and ever-ready
instinctive system that is
characteristic of man thought forms
universally understandable gestures and
many attitudes follow a pattern that was
established long before man developed a
reflective consciousness it is even
conceivable that the early origins of
man's capacity to reflect come from the
painful consequences of violent
emotional clashes let me take purely as
an illustration of this point the
Bushmen who in a moment of anger and
disappointment as his failure to catch
any fish strangles his much beloved only
son and is then seized with immense
regret as he holds the little dead body
in his arms such a man might remember
this moment of Fame forever we cannot
know whether this kind of experience was
actually the initial
of the development of human
consciousness but there is no doubt that
the shock of a similar emotional
experience is often needed to make
people wake up and pay attention to what
they are doing there is a famous case of
a thirteenth century Spanish Hidalgo but
I'm only who finally after a long chase
succeeded in meeting the lady he admired
at a secret rendezvous she silently
opened her dress and showed him her
breast rotten with cancer the shock
changed Lulu's life he eventually became
an eminent theologian and one of the
church's greatest missionaries in the
case of such a sudden change one can
often prove that an archetype has been
at work for a long time in the
unconscious skillfully arranging
circumstances that will lead to the
crisis such experiences seemed to show
that archetypal forms are not just
static patterns they are dynamic factors
that manifest themselves in impulses
just as spontaneously as the instinct
certain dreams visions or thoughts can
suddenly appear and however carefully
one investigates one cannot find out
what causes them this does not mean that
they have no cause they certainly have
but it is so remote or obscure that one
cannot see what it is in such a case one
must wait either until the dream and its
meaning are sufficiently understood or
until some external event occurs that
will explain the dream at the moment of
the dream this event may still lie in
the future but just as our conscious
thoughts often occupy themselves with
the future and its possibilities so do
the unconscious and its dreams there has
long been a general belief that the
chief function of Dreams is
prognostication of the future in
antiquity and as late as the Middle Ages
dreams played their part in medical
prognosis I can confirm by a modern
dream the element of prognosis or
precognition that can be found in an old
dream quoted by Artem odorous of Dallas
in the second century AD a man dreamed
that he saw his father die in the flames
of a house on fire not long afterwards
he himself died in a flight
monie fire or high fever which I presume
was pneumonia it so happened that a
colleague of mine was once suffering
from a deadly gangrenous fever in fact a
flag monie a former patient of his who
had no knowledge of the nature of his
doctors illness dreamed that the doctor
died in a great fire at that time the
doctor had just entered a hospital and
the disease was only beginning the
dreamer knew nothing but the bare fact
that his doctor was ill and in a
hospital three weeks later the doctor
died as this example shows dreams may
have an anticipatory or prognostic
aspect and anybody trying to interpret
them must take this into consideration
especially where an obviously meaningful
dream does not provide a context
sufficient to explain it
such a dream often comes right out of
the blue and one wonders what could have
prompted it of course if one knew its
ulterior message its cause would be
clear for it is only our consciousness
that does not yet know the unconscious
seems already informed and to have come
to a conclusion that is expressed in the
dream in fact the unconscious seems to
be able to examine and to draw
conclusions from facts much as
consciousness does it can even use
certain facts and anticipate their
possible results just because we are not
conscious of them but as far as one can
make out from dreams the unconscious
makes its deliberations instinctively
the distinction is important logical
analysis is the prerogative of
consciousness we select with reason and
knowledge the unconscious however seems
to be guided chiefly by instinctive
trends represented by corresponding
thought forms that is by the archetypes
a doctor who is asked to describe the
course of an illness will use such
rational concepts as infection or fever
the dream is more poetic it presents the
diseased body as a man's earthly house
and the fever as the fire that is
destroying it as the above dream shows
the archetypal mind has handled the
situation in the same way as it did in
the
artim odorous something that is of a
more or less unknown nature has been
intuitively grasped by the unconscious
and submitted to an archetypal treatment
this suggests that instead of process of
reasoning that conscious thought would
have applied the archetypal mind has
stepped in and taken over the task of
prognostication the archetypes thus have
their own initiative and their own
specific energy these powers enable them
both to produce a meaningful
interpretation in their own symbolic
style and to interfere in a given
situation with their own impulses and
their own thought formations in this
respect they function like complexes
they come and go very much as they
please and often they obstruct or modify
our conscious intentions in an
embarrassing way we can perceive the
specific energy of archetypes when we
experience the peculiar fascination that
accompanies them they seem to hold a
special spell such a peculiar quality is
also characteristic of the personal
complexes and just as personal complexes
have their individual history so to
social complexes of an archetypal
character but while personal complexes
never produce more than a personal bias
archetypes create myths religions and
philosophies that influence and
characterize whole nations and epochs of
history we regard the personal complexes
as compensations for one-sided or faulty
attitudes of consciousness in the same
way myths of a religious nature can be
interpreted as a sort of mental therapy
for the sufferings and anxieties of
mankind in general hunger war disease
old age death the Universal hero myth
for example always refers to a powerful
man or God man who vanquishes evil in
the form of dragons serpents monsters
demons and so on and who liberates his
people from destruction and death
the narration or ritual repetition of
sacred texts and ceremonies and the
worship of such a figure with dances
music hymns prayers and sacrifices
gripped the audience with numinous
emotions as if with magic spells and
exalt the individual to an
identification
with the hero if we try to see such a
situation with the eyes of a believer we
can perhaps understand how the ordinary
man can be liberated from his personal
impotence and misery and endowed at
least temporarily with an almost
superhuman quality often enough such a
conviction will sustain him for a long
time and give a certain style to his
life it may even set the tone of a whole
society a remarkable instance of this
can be found in the aleutian Ian's
mysteries which were finally suppressed
at the beginning of the 7th century of
the Christian era they expressed
together with the Delphic Oracle the
essence and spirit of ancient Greece on
a much greater scale the Christian era
itself owes its name and significance to
the antique mystery of the god man which
has its roots in the archetypal Osiris
Horus myth of ancient Egypt it is
commonly assumed that on some given
occasion in prehistoric times the basic
mythological ideas were invented by a
clever old philosopher or prophet and
ever afterward believed by a credulous
and uncritical people it is said that
story is told by a power seeking priests
to it are not true but merely wishful
thinking but the very word invent is
derived from the Latin in vanity and
means to find and hence to find
something by seeking it in the latter
case the word itself hints at some
foreknowledge of what you were going to
find let me go back to the strange ideas
contained in the dreams of the little
girl it seems unlikely that she sought
them out since she was surprised to find
them they occurred to her rather as
peculiar and unexpected stories which
seemed noteworthy enough to be given to
her father as a Christmas present in
doing so however she lifted them up into
the sphere of our still living Christian
mystery the birth of our Lord mixed with
the secret of the evergreen tree that
carries the newborn light this is the
reference of the fifth dream although
there is ample historical evidence for
the symbolic relation between Christ and
the tree symbol the little girl's
parents would have been grave
embarrassed had they been asked to
explain exactly what they meant by
decorating a tree with burning candles
to celebrate the Nativity of Christ oh
it's just a Christmas custom they would
have said a serious answer would require
a far-reaching dissertation about the
antique symbolism of the dying God and
its relation to the cult of the great
mother and her symbol the tree to
mention only one aspect of this
complicated problem the further we delve
into the origins of a collective image
or to express it in ecclesiastical
language of a dogma the more we uncover
a seemingly unending web of archetypal
patterns that before modern times were
never the object of conscious reflection
thus paradoxically enough we know more
about mythological symbolism than did
any generation before our own the fact
is that in former times men did not
reflect upon their symbols they lived
them and were unconsciously animated by
their meaning I will illustrate this by
an experience I once had with the
primitives of Mount Elgon in Africa
every morning at dawn they leave their
huts and breathe or spit into their
hands which they then stretch out to the
first rays of the Sun as if they were
offering either their breath or their
spittle to the Rising God to Mungo this
swahili word which they used in
explaining the ritual act is derived
from a polynesian root equivalent to
mana or Mulungu these and similar terms
designate a power of extraordinary
efficiency and pervasiveness which we
should call divine thus the word Mungo
is their equivalent for Allah or God
when I asked them what they meant by
this act or why they did it they were
completely baffled they could only say
we have always done it it has always
been done when the Sun rises they
laughed at the obvious conclusion that
the Sun is mangu the Sun indeed is not
moon goo when it is above the horizon
Mungo is the actual moment of the
sunrise what they were doing was obvious
to me but not to them they just did it
never reflecting on what they did they
were consequently unable to explain
themselves I concluded
they were offering their souls to Mungo
because the breath of life and the
spittle meant sole substance to breathe
or spit upon something conveys a magical
effect as for instance when Christ used
spittle to cure the blind or where a son
inhales his dying father's last breath
in order to take over the father's soul
it is most unlikely that these Africans
ever even in the remote past knew any
more about the meaning of their ceremony
in fact their ancestors probably knew
even less because they were even more
profoundly unconscious of their motives
and thought less about their doings
goodas Faust aptly says him unfun kotti
taught in the beginning was the deed
deeds were never invented they were done
thoughts on the other hand are a
relatively late discovery of man first
he was moved to deeds by unconscious
factors it was only a long time
afterward that he began to reflect upon
the causes that had moved him and it
took him a very long time indeed to
arrive at the preposterous idea that he
must have moved himself his mind being
unable to identify any other motivating
force than his own
we should laugh at the idea of a plant
or an animal inventing itself yet there
are many people who believe that the
psyche or mind invented itself and thus
was the creator of its own existence as
a matter of fact the mind has grown to
its present state of consciousness as an
acorn grows into an oak or as saurians
developed in the mammals as it has for
so long been developing so it still
develops and thus we are moved by forces
from within as well as by stimuli from
without these inner motives spring from
a deep source that is not made by
consciousness and is not under its
control in the mythology of earlier
times these forces were called mana or
spirits demons and gods they are as
active today as they ever were if they
conform to our wishes we call them happy
hunches or impulses and pat ourselves on
the back for being smart fellows if they
go against us then we say that it is
just bad luck or that certain people are
against
or that the cause of our misfortunes
must be pathological the one thing we
refuse to admit is that we are dependent
upon powers that are beyond our control
it is true however that in recent time
civilized man has acquired a certain
amount of willpower which he can apply
where he pleases he has learned to do
his work efficiently without having
recourse to chatting and drumming to
hypnotize him into a state of doing he
can even dispense with a daily prayer
for divine aid he can carry out what he
proposes to do and he can apparently
translate his ideas into action without
a hitch whereas the primitive seems to
be hampered at each step by fears
superstitions and other unseen obstacles
to action the motto
where there's a will there's a way is
the superstition of modern man yet in
order to sustain his Creed contemporary
man pays the price in a remarkable lack
of introspection he is blind to the fact
that with all his rationality and
deficiency he is possessed by powers
that are beyond his control his gods and
demons have not disappeared at all they
have merely gotten new names they keep
him on the run with restlessness vague
apprehensions psychological
complications an insatiable need for
pills alcohol tobacco food and above all
a large array of neuroses the soul of
man what we call civilized consciousness
has steadily separated itself from the
basic instinct but these instincts have
not disappeared they have nearly lost
their contact with our consciousness and
are thus forced to assert themselves in
an indirect fashion this may be by means
of physical symptoms as in the case of a
neurosis or by means of incidents of
various kinds such as unaccountable
moods unexpected forgetfulness or
mistakes in speech a man likes to
believe that he is the master of his
soul but as long as he is unable to
control his moods and emotions or to be
conscious of the myriad secret ways in
which unconscious factors insinuate
themselves into his arrangements and
decisions he is certainly not his own
these unconscious factors owe their
existence to the autonomy of the
archetypes modern man protects himself
against seeing his own split state by a
system of compartments certain areas of
outer life and of his own behavior are
kept as it were in separate drawers and
are never confronted with one another as
an example of this so-called compartment
psychology I remember the case of an
alcoholic who had come under the
laudable influence of a certain
religious movement and fascinated by its
enthusiasm had forgotten that he needed
the drink he was obviously and
miraculously cured by Jesus and he was
correspondingly displayed as a witness
to divine grace or to the efficiency of
the said religious organization but
after a few weeks of public confessions
the novelty began to pale and some
alcoholic refreshment seemed to be
indicated and so he drank again but this
time the helpful organization came to
the conclusion that the case was
pathological and obviously not suitable
for an intervention by Jesus so they put
him into a clinic to let the doctor do
better than the divine healer this is an
aspect of the modern cultural mind that
is worth looking into it shows an
alarming degree of dissociation and
psychological confusion if for a moment
we regard mankind as one individual we
see that the human race is like a person
carried away by unconscious powers and
the human race also likes to keep
certain problems tucked away in separate
drawers but this is why we should give a
great deal of consideration to what we
are doing for mankind is now threatened
by self-created and deadly dangers that
are growing beyond our control our world
is so to speak dissociated like a
neurotic with the iron curtain marking
the symbolic line of division Western
man becoming aware of the aggressive
will to power of the East sees himself
forced to take extraordinary measures of
defense at the same time as he prides
himself on his virtue and good
intentions what he fails to see is that
it is his own vices which he has covered
up by good
manners that are thrown back in his face
by the Communist world shamelessly and
methodically what the West has tolerated
but secretly and with a sense of shame
the diplomatic lysosome attic deception
veiled threats comes back into the open
and in full measure from the east and
ties us up in neurotic knots it is the
face of his own evil shadow that grins
at Western man from the other side of
the Iron Curtain it is this state of
affairs that explains the peculiar
feeling of helplessness of so many
people in Western societies they have
begun to realize that the difficulties
confronting us are moral problems and
that the attempts to answer them by a
policy of piling up nuclear arms or by
economic competition is achieving little
for it cuts both ways many of us now
understand that moral and mental means
would be more efficient since they could
provide us with psychic immunity against
the ever increasing infection but all
such attempts have proved singularly
ineffective and will do so as long as we
try to convince ourselves and the world
that it is only they that is our
opponents who are wrong it would be much
more to the point for us to make a
serious attempt to recognize our own
shadow and its nefarious doings if we
could see our shadow the dark side of
our nature we should be immune to any
moral and mental infection and
insinuation as matters now stand we lay
ourselves open to every infection
because we are really doing practically
the same thing as they only we have the
additional disadvantage that we neither
see nor want to understand what we
ourselves are doing under the cover of
good manners the Communist world it may
be noted as one big myth which we call
an illusion in the vain hope that our
superior judgment will make it disappear
it is the time hallowed archetypal dream
of a Golden Age or paradise where
everything is provided in abundance for
everyone and a great just and wise chief
rules over a human kindergarten this
powerful archetype in its infantile form
has gripped them but it will never
disappear from the world at the mere
sight of our superior point of view we
even support it by our own childishness
for our Western
is in the grip of the same mythology
unconsciously we cherish the same
prejudices hopes and expectations we too
believe in the welfare state in
universal peace in the Equality of man
in his eternal human rights injustice
truth and do not say it too loudly in
the kingdom of God on earth the sad
truth is that man's real life consists
of a complex of inexorable opposites day
and night birth and death happiness and
misery good and evil we are not even
sure that one will prevail against the
other that good will overcome evil or
joy defeat pain life is a battleground
it always has been and always will be
and if it were not so existence would
come to an end it was precisely this
conflict within man that led the early
Christians to expect and hope for an
early end to this world or the Buddhists
to reject all earthly desires and
aspirations these basic answers would be
frankly suicidal if they were not linked
up with peculiar mental and moral ideas
and practices that constitute the bulk
of both religions and that to a certain
extent modify their radical denial of
the world I stressed this point because
in our time there are millions of people
who have lost faith in any kind of
religion such people do not understand
their religion any longer while life
runs smoothly without religion the loss
remains as good as unnoticed but when
suffering comes it is another matter
that is when people begin to seek a way
out and to reflect about the meaning of
life and it's bewildering and painful
experiences it is significant that the
psychological doctor within my
experience is consulted more by Jews and
Protestants than by Catholics this might
be expected for the Catholic Church
still feels responsible for the Kuta a
new modern the care and welfare of souls
but in this scientific age the
psychiatrist is apt to be asked the
questions that once belonged in the
domain of the theologians people feel
that it makes or would make a great
difference if only they had a positive
belief in a meaningful way of life or in
God and immortality the specter of
approach
death often gives the powerful incentive
to such thoughts from time immemorial
men have had ideas about a Supreme Being
one or several and about the land of the
hereafter only today do they think they
can do without such ideas because we
cannot discover God's throne in the sky
with a radio telescope or established
for certain that a beloved father or
mother is still about in a more or less
corporeal form people assume that such
ideas are not true I would rather say
that they are not true enough for these
our conceptions of a kind that have
accompanied human life from prehistoric
times and that still break through into
consciousness at any provocation modern
man may assert that he can dispense with
them and he may bolster his opinion by
insisting that there is no scientific
evidence of their truth or he may even
regret the loss of his convictions but
since we are dealing with invisible and
unknowable things for God is beyond
human understanding and there is no
means of proving immortality why should
we bother about evidence even if we did
not know by reason our need for salt in
our food we should nonetheless profit
from its use we might argue that the use
of salt is a mere illusion of taste or a
superstition but it would still
contribute to our well-being why then
should we deprive ourselves of views
that would prove helpful in crises and
would give a meaning to our existence
and how do we know that such ideas are
not true many people would agree with me
if I stated flatly that such ideas are
probably illusions what they fail to
realize is that the denial is as
impossible to prove as the assertion of
religious belief we are entirely free to
choose which point of view we take it
will in any case be an arbitrary
decision there is however a strong
empirical reason why we should cultivate
thoughts that can never be proved it is
that they are known to be useful man
positively needs general ideas and
convictions that will give a meaning to
his life and enable him to find a place
for himself in the universe he can stand
the most incredible hardships when he is
convinced that they make sense he is
crushed when
on top of all his misfortunes he has to
admit that he is taking part in a tale
told by an idiot it is the role of
religious symbols to give a meaning to
the life of man
the Pueblo Indians believed that they
are the sons of fathers son and this
belief in dows their life with a
perspective and a goal that goes far
beyond their limited existence
it gives them Apple space for the
unfolding of personality and permits
them a full life as complete persons
their plight is infinitely more
satisfactory than that of a man in our
own civilization who knows that he is
and will remain nothing more than an
underdog with no inner meaning to his
life a sense of a wider meaning to one's
existence is what raises a man beyond
mere getting in spending if he lacks
this sense he is lost and miserable had
Saint Paul been convinced that he was
nothing more than a wandering cat maker
he certainly would not have been the man
he was his real and meaningful life lay
in the inner certainty that he was the
messenger of the Lord one may accuse him
of suffering from megalomania but this
opinion pales before the testimony of
history and the judgment of subsequent
generations the myth that took
possession of him made him something
greater than a mere craftsman such a
myth however consists of symbols that
have not been invented consciously they
have happened it was not the man Jesus
who created the myth of the god man it
existed for many centuries before his
birth he himself was seized by this
symbolic idea which st. mark tells us
lifted him out of the narrow life of the
Nazarene carpenter myths go back to the
primitive storyteller and his dreams two
men moved by the stirring of their
fantasies these people were not very
different from those from later
generations have called poets or
philosophers primitive storytellers did
not concern themselves with the origin
of their fantasies it was very much
later that people began to wonder where
a story originated yet centuries ago in
what we now call ancient Greece men's
minds were advanced enough to surmise
that the tales of the gods were nothing
but archaic and exaggerated traditions
of
varied kings or chieftains men already
took the view that the myth was too
improbable to mean what it said they
therefore tried to reduce it to a
generally understandable form in more
recent times we have seen the same thing
happen with dream symbolism we became
aware in the years when psychology was
in its infancy the dreams had some
importance but just as the Greeks
persuaded themselves that their myths
were merely elaborations of rational or
normal history so some of the pioneers
of psychology came to the conclusion
that dreams did not mean what they
appeared to mean the images were symbols
that they presented were dismissed as
bizarre forms in which repressed
contents of the psyche appeared to the
conscious mind if the same to be taken
for granted
that a dream meant something other than
its obvious statement I have already
described my disagreement with this idea
a disagreement that led me to study the
form as well as the content of greens
why should they mean something different
from their contents is there anything in
nature that is other than it is the
dream is a normal and natural phenomenon
and it does not mean something it is not
the Talmud even says the dream is its
own interpretation the confusion arises
because the dreams contents are symbolic
and thus have more than one meaning the
symbols point in different directions
from those we apprehend with the
conscious mind and therefore they relate
to something either unconscious or at
least not entirely conscious to the
scientific mind such phenomena as
symbolic ideas are a nuisance because
they cannot be formulated in a way that
is satisfactory to intellect and logic
they are by no means the only case of
this kind in psychology the trouble
begins with the phenomenon of affect or
emotion which evades all the attempts of
the psychologists to pin it down with
the final definitions the cars of the
difficulty is the same in both cases the
intervention of the unconscious I know
enough of the scientific point of view
to understand that it is most annoying
to have to deal with facts that cannot
be completely or adequately grasped the
trouble with these phenomena is that the
fact
undeniable and yet cannot be formulated
in intellectual terms for this one would
have to be able to comprehend life
itself for it is life that produces
emotions and symbolic ideas the academic
psychologist is perfectly free to
dismiss the phenomenon of emotion or the
concept of the unconscious or both from
his consideration yet they remain facts
to which the medical psychologist at
least has to pay due attention for
emotional conflicts and the intervention
of the unconscious are the classical
features of his science if he treats a
patient at all he comes up against these
irrationalities as hard facts
irrespective of his ability to formulate
them in intellectual terms it is
therefore quite natural that people who
have not had the medical psychologists
experience find it difficult to follow
what happens when psychology ceases to
be a tranquil pursuit for the scientists
in his laboratory and becomes an active
part of the adventure of real-life
target practice on a shooting range is
far from the battlefield the doctor has
to deal with casualties in a genuine war
he must concern himself with psychic
realities even if he cannot embody them
in scientific definitions that is why no
textbook can teach psychology one learns
only by actual experience we can see
this point clearly when we examine
certain well-known symbols the cross in
the Christian religion for instance is a
meaningful symbol that expresses a
multitude of aspects ideas and emotions
but a cross after a name on a list
simply indicates that the individual is
dead the phallus functions as an
all-embracing symbol in the hindu
religion but if a street urchin draws
one on a wall it just reflects an
interest in his penis because infantile
and adolescent fantasies often continue
far into adult life many dreams occur in
which there are unmistakable sexual
allusions it would be absurd to
understand them as anything else but
when a Mason speaks of monks and nuns to
be laid upon each other or an
electrician of mail plugs and female
socket it would be ludicrous
suppose that he is indulging in glowing
adolescent fantasies he is simply using
colorful descriptive names for his
materials when an educated Hindu talks
to you about the Lingam the phallus that
represents the god Shiva in Hindu
mythology you will hear things we
Westerners would never connect with the
penis the Lingam is certainly not an
obscene illusion nor is the cross merely
a sign of death much depends upon the
maturity of the dreamer who produces
such an image the interpretation of
dreams and symbols demands intelligence
it cannot be turned into a mechanical
system and then crammed into
unimaginative brains it demands both an
increasing knowledge of the dreamers
individuality and an increasing
self-awareness on the part of the
interpreter no experienced worker in
this field will deny that there are
rules of thumb that can prove helpful
but they must be applied with prudence
and intelligence when they follow all
the right rules and yet get bogged down
in the most appalling nonsense simply by
overlooking a seemingly unimportant
detail that a better intelligence would
not have missed even a man of high
intellect can go badly astray for lack
of intuition or feeling when we attempt
to understand symbols we are not only
confronted with the symbol itself but we
are brought up against the wholeness of
the symbol producing individual this
includes a study of his cultural
background and in the process one fills
in many gaps in one's own education I
have made it a rule myself to consider
every case as an entirely new
proposition about which I do not even
know the ABC routine responses may be
practical and useful while one is
dealing with the surface but as soon as
one gets in touch with the vital
problems life itself takes over and even
the most brilliant theoretical premises
become ineffectual words imagination and
intuition are vital to our understanding
and though the usual popular opinion is
that they are chiefly valuable to poets
and artists that in sensible matters one
should mistrust them they are in fact
equally vital in all the higher grades
of science
here they play an increasingly important
role which supplements that of the
rational intellect and its application
to a specific problem even physics the
strictest of all Applied Sciences
depends to an astonishing degree upon
intuition which works by way of the
unconscious although it is possible to
demonstrate afterward the logical
procedures that could have led one to
the same result as intuition intuition
is almost indispensable in the
interpretation of symbols and it can
often ensure that they are immediately
understood by the dreamer but while such
a lucky hunch may be subjectively
convincing it can also be rather
dangerous it can so easily lead to a
false feeling of security it may for
instance seduce both the interpreter and
the dreamer into continuing a cosy and
relatively easy relation which may end
in a sort of shared dream the safe basis
of real intellectual knowledge and moral
understanding gets lost if one is
content with the vague satisfaction of
having understood by hunch one can
explain and know only if one is reduced
intuitions to an exact knowledge of
facts and their logical connections an
honest investigator will have to admit
that he cannot always do this but it
would be dishonest not to keep it always
in mind even a scientist is a human
being so it is natural for him like
others to hate the things he cannot
explain it is a common illusion to
believe that what we know today is all
we ever can know nothing is more
vulnerable than scientific theory which
is an ephemeral attempt to explain facts
and not an everlasting truth in itself
the role of symbols when the medical
psychologist takes an interest in
symbols he is primarily concerned with
natural symbols as distinct from
cultural symbols the former are derived
from the unconscious contents of the
psyche and they therefore represent an
enormous number of variations on the
essential archetypal images in many
cases they can still be traced back to
their archaic roots that is to ideas and
images that we meet in the most ancient
record
and in primitive societies the cultural
symbols on the other hand are those that
have been used to express eternal truths
and that are still used in many
religions they have gone through many
transformations and even a long process
of more or less conscious development
and address become collective images
accepted by civilized societies such
cultural symbols nevertheless retain
much of their original numerosity or
spell one is aware that they can evoke a
deep emotional response in some
individuals and this psychic change
makes them function in much the same way
as prejudices they are a factor with
which the psychologists must reckon it
is folly to dismiss them because in
rational terms they seem to be absurd or
irrelevant they are important
constituents of our mental makeup and
vital forces in the building up of human
society and they cannot be eradicated
without serious loss where they are
repressed or neglected their specific
energy disappears into the unconscious
with unaccountable consequences the
psychic energy that appears to have been
lost in this way in fact serves to
revive and intensify whatever is
uppermost in the unconscious tendencies
perhaps that have hitherto had no chance
to express themselves or at least have
not been allowed an uninhibited
existence in our consciousness such
tendencies form an ever-present and
potentially destructive shadow to our
conscious mind even tendencies that
might in some circumstances be able to
exert a beneficial influence are
transformed into demons when they are
repressed this is why many well-meaning
people are understandably afraid of the
unconscious and incidentally of
psychology our times have demonstrated
what it means for the gates of the
underworld to be opened things whose
enormity nobody could have imagined in
the idyllic harmlessness of the first
decade of our century have happened and
have turned our world upside down ever
since the world has remained in a state
of schizophrenia
not only has civilized Germany disgorged
it's terrible primitivity but Russia is
also ruled by
and Africa has been set on fire no
wonder that the Western world feels
uneasy modern man does not understand
how much his rationalism which has
destroyed his capacity to respond to
numinous symbols and ideas has put him
at the mercy of the psychic underworld
he has freed himself from superstition
or so he believes but in the process he
has lost his spiritual values to a
positively dangerous degree his moral
and spiritual tradition has
disintegrated and he is now paying the
price for this breakup in worldwide
disorientation and dissociation
anthropologists have often described
what happens to a primitive society when
its spiritual values are exposed to the
impact of modern civilization it's
people lose the meaning of their lives
their social organization disintegrates
and they themselves morally decay we are
now in the same condition but we have
never really understood what we have
lost for our spiritual leaders
unfortunately were more interested in
protecting their institutions than in
understanding the mystery that symbols
present in my opinion faith does not
exclude thought which is man's strongest
weapon but unfortunately many believers
seem to be so afraid of science and
incidentally of psychology that they
turn a blind eye to the numinous psychic
powers that forever control man's fate
we have stripped all things of their
mystery and new manasa t nothing is holy
any longer in earlier ages as
instinctive concepts welled up in the
mind of man his conscious mind could no
doubt integrate them into a coherent
psychic pattern but the civilized man is
no longer able to do this his advanced
consciousness has deprived itself of the
means by which the auxiliary
contributions of the instincts and the
unconscious can be assimilated these
organs of assimilation and integration
were numinous symbols held wholly by
common consent today for instance we
talk of matter we describe its physical
properties we conduct laboratory
experiments to demonstrate some of its
aspects but the word matter remains a
dry
in human and purely intellectual concept
without any psychic significance for us
how different was the former image of
mater the great mother that could
encompass and Express the profound
emotional meaning of Mother Earth in the
same way what was the spirit is now
identified with intellect and thus
ceases to be the father of all it is
degenerated to the limited ego thoughts
of man the immense emotional energy
expressed in the image of our Father
vanishes into the sand of an
intellectual desert these two archetypal
principles lie at the foundation of the
contrasting systems of east and west the
masses and their leaders do not realize
however that there is no substantial
difference between calling the world
principle male and a father spirit as
the West does or female and the mother
matter as the Communists do essentially
we know as little of the one as of the
other in earlier times these principles
were worshiped in all sorts of rituals
which at least showed the psychic
significance they held for men but now
they have become mere abstract concepts
as scientific understanding has grown so
our world has become dehumanized man
feels himself isolated in the cosmos
because he is no longer involved in
nature and has lost his emotional
unconscious identity with natural
phenomena these have slowly lost their
symbolic implications Thunder is no
longer the voice of an angry god nor is
lightning his avenging missile no River
contains a spirit no tree is the life
principle of a man no snake the
embodiment of wisdom no mountain cave
the home of a great demon no voices now
speak to man from stones plants and
animals nor does he speak to them
believing they can hear his contact with
nature has gone and with it has gone the
profound emotional energy that this
symbolic connection supplied this
enormous loss is compensated for by the
symbols of our dreams they bring up our
original nature its instincts and
peculiar thinking on four
however they express their contents in
the language of nature which is strange
and incomprehensible to us
it therefore confronts us with the task
of translating it into the rational
words and concepts of modern speech
which has liberated itself from its
primitive encumbrances notably from its
mystical participation with the things
it describes
nowadays when we talk of ghosts and
other numinous figures we are no longer
conjuring them up the power as well as
the glory is drained out of such once
potent words we have ceased to believe
in magic formulas not many taboos and
similar restrictions are left and our
world seems to be disinfected of all
such superstitious new mana as witches
warlocks and were EKU's to say nothing
of were wolves vampires bush souls and
all the other bizarre beings that
populated the primeval forest to be more
accurate the surface of our world seems
to be cleansed of all superstitious and
irrational elements whether however the
real inner human world not our wish
fulfilling fiction about it is also
freed from primitivity is another
question is the number thirteen not
still taboo for many people are there
not still many individuals possessed by
irrational prejudices projections and
childish illusions a realistic picture
of the human mind reveals many such
primitive traits and survivals which are
still playing their roles just as if
nothing had happened during the last
five hundred years it is essential to
appreciate this point modern man is in
fact a curious mixture of
characteristics acquired over the long
ages of his mental development this
mixed up being is the man and his
symbols that we have to deal with and we
must scrutinize his mental products very
carefully indeed skepticism and
scientific conviction existing him
side-by-side with old-fashioned
prejudices outdated habits of thought
and feeling obstinate misinterpretations
and blind ignorance such are the
contemporary human beings who produced
the symbols we psychologists investigate
in order to explain these symbols and
their meaning it is vital to
whether they're representations are
related to purely personal experience or
whether they have been chosen by a dream
for its particular purpose from a store
of general conscious knowledge take for
instance a dream in which the number
thirteen occurs the question is whether
the dreamer himself habitually believes
in the unlucky quality of the number or
whether the dream merely alludes to
people who still indulge in such
superstitions the answer makes a great
difference to the interpretation in the
former case you have to reckon with the
fact that the individual is still under
the spell of the unlucky 13 and
therefore it will feel most
uncomfortable in room 13 in a hotel or
sitting at a table with 13 people in the
latter case 13 may not mean any more
than a discourteous or abusive remarks
the superstitious dreamer still feels
the spell of 13 the more rational
dreamer has stripped 13 of its original
emotional overtones this argument
illustrates the way in which archetypes
appear in practical experience they are
at the same time both images and
emotions one can speak of an archetype
only when these two aspects are
simultaneous when there is merely the
image then there is simply a word
picture of little consequence but by
being charged with emotion the image
gains new manasa T or psychic energy it
becomes dynamic and consequences of some
kind must flow from it I am aware that
it is difficult to grasp this concept
because I am trying to use words to
describe something whose very nature
makes it incapable of precise
definitions but since so many people
have chosen to treat archetypes as if
they were part of the mechanical system
that can be learned by rote it is
essential to insist that they are not
mere names or even philosophical
concepts they are pieces of life itself
images that are integrally connected to
the living individual by the bridge of
the emotions that is why it is
impossible to give an arbitrary or
universal interpretation of any
archetype it must be explained in the
manner indicated by the whole life
situation of the particulars it relates
thus in the case of a
without Christian the symbol of the
cross can be interpreted only in its
Christian context unless the dream
produces a very strong reason to look
beyond it even then the specific
Christian meaning should be kept in mind
but one cannot say that at all times and
in all circumstances the symbol of the
cross has the same meaning if that were
so it would be stripped of its new
Manasa t lose its vitality and become a
mere word those who do not realize the
special feeling tone of the archetype
end with nothing more than a jumble of
mythological concepts which can be
strung together to show that everything
means anything or nothing at all all the
corpses in the world are chemically
identical but living individuals are not
archetypes come to life only when one
patiently tries to discover why and in
what fashion they are meaningful to a
living individual the mere use of words
is futile when you do not know what they
stand for this is particularly true in
psychology where we speak of archetypes
such as the anima and animus the wise
man the Great Mother and so on you can
know all about the saints sages prophets
and other godly men and all the great
mothers of the world but if they are
mirror images whose new Manasa T you
have never experienced it will be as if
you were talking in a dream for you will
not know what you are talking about the
mere words you use will be empty and
valueless they gain life and meaning
only when you try to take into account
their new Manasa T that is their
relationship to the living individual
only then do you begin to understand
that their names mean very little
whereas the way they are related to you
is all-important the symbol producing
function of our dreams is thus an
attempt to bring the original mind of
man into advanced or differentiated
consciousness where it has never been
before and where therefore it has never
been subjected to critical
self-reflection for in ages long past
that original mind was the whole of
man's personality as he developed
consciousness so his conscious mind lost
contact with some of that primitive
psychic energy
and the conscious mind has never known
that original mind for it was discarded
in the process of evolving the very
differentiated consciousness that alone
could be aware of it yet it seems that
what we call the unconscious has
preserved primitive characteristics that
formed part of the original mind it is
to these characteristics that the
symbols of dreams constantly refer as if
the unconscious sought to bring back all
the old things from which the mind freed
itself as it evolved illusions fantasies
archaic thought forms fundamental
instincts and so on this is what
explains the resistance even fear that
people often experience in approaching
unconscious matters these relict
contents are not merely neutral or
indifferent on the contrary they are so
highly charged that they are often more
than merely uncomfortable they can cause
real fear the more they are repressed
the more they spread through the whole
personality in the form of a neurosis it
is this psychic energy that gives them
such a vital importance it is just as if
a man who has lived through a period of
unconsciousness should suddenly realize
that there is a gap in his memory that
important events seem to have taken
place that he cannot remember insofar as
he assumes that the psyche is an
exclusively personal affair and this is
the usual assumption he will try to
retrieve the apparently lost infantile
memories but the gaps in his childhood
memory are merely the symptoms of a much
greater loss the loss of the primitive
psyche as the evolution of the embryonic
body repeats its prehistory
so the mind also develops through a
series of prehistoric stages the main
task of dreams is to bring back a sort
of recollection of the prehistoric as
well as the infantile world right down
to the level of the most primitive
instincts such recollections can have a
remarkably healing effect in certain
cases as Freud so long ago this
observation confirms the view that an
infantile memory gap the so called
amnesia represents a positive loss and
its recovery can bring a positive
increase in life and well-being because
a child is physically small and if
conscious thoughts are scarce and simple
we do not realize that far-reaching
complications of the infantile mind that
are based on its original identity with
the prehistoric psyche that original
mind is just as much present and still
functioning in the child as the
evolutionary stages of mankind are in
its embryonic body if the reader
remembers what I said earlier about the
remarkable dreams of the child who made
a present of her dreams to her father he
will get a good idea of what I mean in
infantile amnesia one fine strange
mythological fragments that also often
appear in later psychosis images of this
kind are highly numinous and therefore
very important if such recollections
reappear in adult life they may in some
cases cause profound psychological
disturbance while in other people they
can produce miracles of healing or
religious conversions often they bring
back a piece of life missing for a long
time that gives purpose to and thus
enriches human life the recollection of
infantile memories and the reproduction
of archetypal ways of psychic behavior
can create a wider horizon and a greater
extension of consciousness on condition
that one succeeds in assimilating and
integrating in the conscious mind the
lost and regained contents since they
are not neutral their assimilation will
modify the personality just as they
themselves will have to undergo certain
alterations in this part of what is
called the individuation process which
dr. ml from France describes in a later
section of this book the interpretation
of symbols plays an important practical
role for the symbols are natural
attempts to reconcile and unite
opposites within the psyche naturally
just seeing and then brushing aside the
symbols would have no such effect and
would merely reestablish the old
neurotic condition and destroy the
attempt at a synthesis but unfortunately
those rare people who do not deny the
very existence of the archetypes almost
invariably treat them as mere words and
forget their living reality when their
new Manasa tea has thus illegitimately
been
the process of limitless substitution
begins in other words one glides easily
from archetype to archetype with
everything meaning everything it is true
enough that the forms of archetypes are
to a considerable extent exchangeable
but there numerosity is and remains a
fact and represents the value of an
archetypal event this emotional value
must be kept in mind and allowed for
throughout the whole intellectual
process of dream interpretation it is
only too easy to lose this value because
thinking and feeling are so
diametrically opposed that thinking
almost automatically throws out feeling
values and vice-versa psychology is the
only science that has to take the factor
of value that is feeling into account
because it is the link between physical
events and life psychology is often
accused of not being scientific on this
account but its critics fail to
understand
the scientific and practical necessity
of giving due consideration to feeling
healing the split our intellect has
created a new world that dominates
nature and has populated it with
monstrous machines the latter are so
indubitably useful that we cannot see
even a possibility of getting rid of
them or our subservience to them man is
bound to follow the adventurous
promptings of his scientific and
inventive mind and to admire himself for
his splendid achievements at the same
time his genius shows the uncanny
tendency to invent things that become
more and more dangerous because they
represent better and better means for
wholesale suicide in view of the rapidly
increasing avalanche of world population
man has already begun to seek ways and
means of keeping the rising flood they
but nature may anticipate all our
attempts by turning against man his own
creative mind the h-bomb for instance
would put an effective stop to
overpopulation in spite of our proud
domination of nature we are still her
victims for we have not even learned to
control our own nature slowly but it
appears inevitably we are courting
disaster there are no longer any gods
whom we can invoke to help us the great
religions of the world suffer from
increasing anemia because the helpful
new mana have fled from the woods rivers
and mountains and from animals and the
Godman have disappeared underground into
the unconscious there we fool ourselves
that they lead an ignominious existence
among the relics of our past our present
lives are dominated by the goddess
reason who is our greatest and most
tragic illusion by the aid of reason so
we assure ourselves we have conquered
nature but this is a mere slogan for the
so called conquest of nature overwhelms
us with the natural fact of
overpopulation and adds to our troubles
by our psychological incapacity to make
the necessary political arrangements it
remains quite natural for men to quarrel
and to struggle for superiority over one
another how then have we conquered
nature
as any change must begin somewhere it is
the single individual who will
experience it and carry it through the
change must indeed begin with an
individual it might be any one of us
nobody can afford to look around and to
wait for somebody else to do what he is
loath to do himself but since nobody
seems to know what to do it might be
worthwhile for each of us to ask himself
whether by any chance his or her
unconscious may know something that will
help us certainly the conscious mind
seems unable to do anything useful in
this respect and today is painfully
aware of the fact that neither his great
religions nor his various philosophies
seemed to provide him with those
powerful animating ideas that would give
him the security he needs in face of the
present condition of the world I know
what the Buddhists would say things
would go right if people would only
follow the Noble Eightfold Path of the
Dharma doctrine law and had true insight
into the self the Christian tells us
that if only people had faith in God we
should have a better world the
rationalist insists that if people were
intelligent and reasonable all our
problems would be manageable the trouble
is that none of them manages to solve
these problems himself Christians often
ask why God does not speak to them as he
is believed to have done in former days
when I hear such questions it always
makes me think of the rabbi who was
asked how it could be that God often
showed himself to people in the olden
days whereas nowadays nobody ever sees
him the rabbi replied nowadays there is
no longer anybody who can bow low enough
this answer hits the nail on the head we
are so captivated by and entangled in
our subjective consciousness that we
have forgotten the age-old fact that God
speaks chiefly through dreams and
visions the Buddhist discards the world
of unconscious fantasies as useless
illusions the Christian puts his church
and his Bible between himself and his
unconscious and the rational
intellectual does not yet know that his
consciousness is not his total psyche
this ignorant persists today in spite of
the fact that for more than seventy
years the unconscious has been a basic
scientific concept that is indispensable
to any serious psychological invest
we can no longer afford to be so god
almighty like us to set ourselves up as
judges of the merits or demerits of
natural phenomena we do not base our
botany upon the old-fashioned division
into useful and useless plants or our
zoology upon the naive distinction
between harmless and dangerous animals
but we still complacently assume that
consciousness is sense and the
unconscious is nonsense in science such
an assumption would be laughed out of
court do microbes for instance make
sense or nonsense
whatever the unconscious may be it is a
natural phenomenon producing symbols
that prove to be meaningful we cannot
expect someone who has never looked
through a microscope to be an authority
on microbes in the same way no one who
has not made a serious study of natural
symbols can be considered a competent
judge in this matter
but the general undervaluation of the
human soul is so great that neither the
great religions nor the philosophies nor
scientific rationalism have been willing
to look at it twice in spite of the fact
that the Catholic Church admits the
occurrence of some Nia and AO Misa
dreams sent by God most of its thinkers
make no serious attempt to understand
dreams I doubt whether there is a
Protestant treatise or a doctrine that
would stoop so low as to admit the
possibility that the Vox Dei might be
perceived in a dream but if a theologian
really believes in God by what authority
does he suggest that God is unable to
speak through dreams I have spent more
than half a century in investigating
natural symbols and I have come to the
conclusion that dreams and their symbols
are not stupid and meaningless
on the contrary dreams provide the most
interesting information for those who
take the trouble to understand their
symbols the results it is true have
little to do with such worldly concerns
as buying and selling but the meaning of
life is not exhaustively explained by
one's business life nor is the deep
desire of the human heart answered by a
bank account in a period of human
history when all available energy is
spent in the investigation of nature
very little attention is paid to the
essence of man which is his psyche
although many researches are made into
its conscious functions but the really
complex and unfamiliar part of the mind
from which symbols are produced is still
virtually unexplored it seems almost
incredible that though we receive
signals from it every night deciphering
these communication seems too tedious
for any but a very few people to be
bothered with it man's greatest
instrument his psyche his little thought
of and it is often directly mistrusted
and disguised it's only psychological to
often means it is nothing where exactly
does this immense prejudice come from we
have obviously been so busy with the
question of what we think that we
entirely forget to ask what the
unconscious psyche thinks about us the
ideas of Sigmund Freud confirmed for
most people the existing contempt for
the psyche before him it had been merely
overlooked and neglected it has now
become a dump for moral refuse this
modern standpoint is surely one-sided
and unjust it does not even accord with
the known facts our actual knowledge of
the unconscious shows that it is a
natural phenomenon and that like Nature
herself is at least neutral it contains
all aspects of human nature light and
dark beautiful and ugly good and evil
profound and silly the study of
individual as well as of collective
symbolism is an enormous task and one
that has not yet been mastered but a
beginning has been made at last the
early results are encouraging and they
seem to indicate an answer to many so
far unanswered questions of present-day
mankind